bonjour et bienvenue pour ce dernier
cours de paléo mammalogie où nous allons
aujourd'hui parler de l'origine des
mammifères parmi les synapses y donnons
malien parmi ce qu'on appelle d'ailleurs
très souvent les les reptiles malien
alors pourquoi terminé par l'origine des
mammifères est bonne parce qu au moins
ça évite de finir sur les homininés
comme le font tous les courts de
mammalogie enfin de paléo mammalogie
donc voilà ça évite de terminer par le
grand classique les hominidés voilà là
le sommet de l'évolution devrais je dire
avec des guillemets donc voilà on va
terminer par l'origine des mammifères et
vous allez voir que c'est un très très
gros morceau donc ça va aller très très
vite
alors on commence déjà par justement les
reptiles malien d'où vient l'idée que
les mammifères descendent des reptiles
entre guillemets et bien reptiles dans
le sens amniotes pas dans le sens soro
psid évidemment et bien tout simplement
parce que les les gens ont rapidement
enfin les scientifiques ont rapidement
remarqué que les mammifères descendait
de d'animaux qui pendaient des oeufs
pourquoi parce qu'on a les
ornithorynques et les équipes n'est donc
les mots notres m qui sont des
mammifères
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus ils
produisent du lait ils ont des poils et
ils pondent aussi d eux donc ils sont
les seuls animaux capables de fabriquer
leur propre crème anglaise
d'ailleurs mais du coup les mots notres
m nous montre que les mammifères ont une
origine parmi des animaux qui avaient
une biologie reptilienne devrais je dire
et donc cette amgn o c'est bien on le
rencontre toujours un chez les
mammifères modernes donc les placentaire
par exemple si vous comparez les couches
sans brio logique qu'on retrouve chez
les placentaire et bien ce sont les
mêmes que celles qu'on retrouve dans
l'oeuf reptilien voilà donc un embryon 1
à mios et puis dans le cordon ombilical
on a les restes de ce qui était
autrefois la lente aux is l'allantoïne
pardon qui est donc l'endroit où sont
stockés les
et les déchets mais qui sont donc
rejetées directement vers le placenta
dans le cadre des placentaires et vous
avez aussi un sac vie terrain qui
dégénère assez rapidement mais on en a
pas besoin puisque on peut directement
échanges et la nourriture avec notre
mère grâce au placenta
mais toutes ces couches embryologie
qu'en fait se retrouve aussi chez les
chez les reptiles et les oiseaux et
c'est ça qui est important à retenir
c'est que les âmes mignotte bazzo avait
une biologie plutôt reptiliennes et
c'est pour ça qu'on parle de reptiles
malien en fait c'est pour refléter un
peu cette biologie reptilienne
qu'avaient les synapses id non malien
donc biologie reptilienne qui va devenir
de plus en plus ma malienne au fil de
leur révolution comme nous allons le
voir donc comment identifie ton les
synapses ide et bien les synapses id
ils ont plusieurs traits ils ont trois
traits principaux en commun donc tous
les synapses ida des plus bazzo que sont
les pays causeur jusqu'aux plus dérivés
que sont les mammifères modernes
on retrouve chez tous les synapses id
les mêmes caractères d'une la présence
d'une canine qui sépare une dentition
près canine d'une dentition post canine
donc vous pouvez la voir à voir ici chez
l'humain vous pouvez le voir ici chez
eux
chez ainsi nos dons et qu'il est donc à
synappci d' vous voyez une canine qui
sépare donc une dentition près canine
qu'on appelle chez les mammifères
modernes des incisives et une dentition
post canine qu'on appelle chez les
mammifères des molaires et il ya même un
moment dans l'évolution des synapses itx
et les sino de traits dérivés où on va
avoir une distinction entre prémolaires
et molères mais ce n'est pas encore le
cas chez les synapses it donc c'est pour
ça qu'on parle de dentition près canine
et post canine c'est parce que les dents
prêts canine ne sont pas encore des
incisives dans le sens où se sont pas
encore des espèces de spatule et les
dents poste canine ne sont pas encore ne
servent pas encore a écrasé à mâcher
chez les ch et les synapses il ou du
moins pas chez tous les synapses id
alors que alors que c'est le cas chez
les chats les mammifères et chez les
mammifères on a une distinction
prémolaires molaires qu'il n'ya pas
encore chez les synapses it donc on
parle de dentition près canine et post
canine
mais voilà le caractère en commun c'est
vraiment la canine
on a évidemment la présence d'une fausse
temporal donc la fosse temporal que vous
voyez ici chez l'homme qui sert
d'insertion muscle temporal qui va
traverser la fosse pour allait
s'attacher ici sur la mandibule et bien
chez les synapses ils ont là aussi chez
tous les synappci donc une fausse
temporal ici qui envoie un muscle qui va
aller s'attacher ici sur le processus
que renault id de la mandibule et puis
ici vous avez ainsi 90 alors chez ceux
ci notons que vous avez une orbite qui
est fusionné à la fosse temporal donc on
voit pas vraiment la différence mais la
fausse t'emporte aller ici et vous voyez
donc le parcours de du muscle temporal
ici avec indiqué par les flèches noires
donc à l'intérieur de la fosse temporal
voilà donc ça c'est la fausse temporal
qui sert à l'index à l'insertion du
muscle muscle temporal et chez les
synapses il on va avoir une tendance à
la réduction des eaux
dix postes dentaire c'est à dire des
eaux à l'arrière de los dentaire sur la
mandibule donc voici lance dentaire en
blanc et vous avez tout un tas d'os à
l'arrière qu'on appelle les oppose
dentaire et ses eaux vont avoir tendance
à se rétrécir et vont ultime en devenir
les eaux de lorraine de l'oreille
moyenne
vous avez les trois aussi kull de
l'oreille moyenne le marteau et
l'enclume l'étrier en fait l'enclume et
le marteau sont des hauts postes poste
dentaire qui se sont transformés et il
ya un des opposants terre qui va aussi
donner la bulletin panique
voilà donc les cte autun panique élan
tota panique sont aussi dérivé de déo
que l'on trouve sur en position poste
dentaire sur la mâchoire des synapses id
on verra tout ça dans le détail donc
voilà l'homologie en fait de ces au
poste dentaire vous avez le stap s qui
devient l'étrier vous avez l'articulet
ray vous avez le carré qui deviennent
respectivement d'oncle articulaires
devient le marteau et le carré devient
l'enclume voilà et tout ça on va on va
voir cette transformation évidemment
dans le détail alors on commence par les
pays causeur pélico szohr avec des
petites guillemets parce que c'est un
groupe qui n'est pas monofil éthique
puisque les il y à un groupe de pays
cause or qui s'appelle laisse fenaco
dont idées et que vous connaissez pas ce
que dit métro dont vous voyez le crâne
ici en fait partie donc ce groupe des
semaines a consenti des est directement
ancestrales otéra psid cetc directement
le groupe qui a donné les thérapies site
donc il ya un groupe de pays causeur qui
est finalement plus proche des thérapies
site qu'il ne l'ait des autres pélico
zor et c'est pour ça qu'on met des
guillemets opéli cosworth est un groupe
paraphe il éthique alors les pays
causeur pour les reconnaître au premier
coup d'oeil au premier coup d'oeil c'est
très simple on regarde la courbe du
crâne
alors j'aime et c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi cette photo c'est parce que cette
photo illustre fort bien le concept de
courbe
n'est ce pas c'est extrêmement sexistes
je devrais me punir je devrais me
flageller je devrais faire un des bonnes
kg pénitence ring pour cette image mais
non voilà c'est pour rire c'est bon puis
c'est pas moi qui les poster sur
internet cette photo là lassé des photos
qu'on trouve sur internet un jeu dia il
ya des femmes à moitié nues qui pose
avec des dix métro donc est ce que vous
voulez vivre la semoy quand vous quand
vous tapez cure voitures du métro dont
c'est ça que vous trouvez sur internet
quoi donc bon bref la courbe au moins
vous vous rappellerez du concept soit
parce que vous l'avez trouvé drôle soit
parce que j'ai choqué votre sensibilité
mais au moins vous vous rappellerai que
s'il ya une courbe
c'est sur le si la marge supérieure du
crâne forme forme une courbe
c'est un pélico or voilà évidemment
c'est pas le seul caractère qu'on
retrouve chez les pélico szohr mais les
pays causant en fait ils sont surtout
caractérisée par le fait qu'ils ont un
crâne qui est très primitif en fait du
point de vue des amniotes donc par
exemple on va voir on a un os lacrymal
qui est très très grand qui forment la
plus grande marche qui forment la
majeure partie de la face voyez que l'os
maxillaire ne sert guère qu'à porter les
dents au final donc cet os lacrymal il
est très grand tellement grand qu'il
atteint la narine
vous voyez ça c'est très caractéristique
vous avez
vous avez des dents sur le palais donc
ça aussi c'est un caractère qui est très
primitive traits reptiliens des dents
même sur les petits rigolos ils vous
voyez ces grosses ranger dentaire sur le
terril go id vous avez encore un foramen
pinéale vous avez encore de nombreux
zoos à l'arrière du crâne voyez qu'il ya
encore du post pariétal du tabulaire
dudus du supra temporal enfin et du vous
avez encore tout le tout la formule
osseuse finalement qu'on retrouve sur le
crâne primitive des amniotes et qu'on
retrouve encore aujourd'hui chez
certains reptiles
on a même encore ce qu'on appelle le
inttra cranial joynt donc l'articulation
intracrânienne alors l'articulation
intracrânienne c'est une articulation
qui se trouve à l'intérieur du crâne
entre la partie est maudite du crade
c'est à dire la partie nasal et la
partie ce phénomène du crâne c'est à
dire la partie
la partie qui correspond à la boîte
crânienne donc à l'intérieur du crâne
vous avez une suture donc une structure
qui se retrouvent qui se trouverait à ce
niveau là vous voyez à l'arrière des
palatin et donc vous ça veut dire que
les le palais à une certaine mobilité
propre c'est à dire qu'un peu comme un
serpent en fait le palais est capable de
bouger par lui-même et de tirer les
proies vers l'arrière et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs vous avez ces grosses dans la
sueur ce sur les chais les pelli causeur
vous avez des grosses dents sur les
petits à rigaud id parce que elle se
plante dans les proies et ensuite le
palais il est capable de bouger
légèrement pour tirer la proie vers
l'arrière donc c'est comme chez les
serpents brand moins développés et ça se
se joint à trac rania cette articulation
intracrânienne ce n'est pas à caractère
dérivés c'est un caractère que les
pélico szohr ont directement héritée des
des amphibiens donc des sites egos et
fall ce qu'on appelle laisse tes gosses
et fall ou les labyrinthes aux dons si
vous préférez ça pas vraiment
d'importance le mot vous utilisez l'idc
c'est pas un caractère dérivés de peli
cosworth et c'est un caractère primitif
évidemment autre caractère primitif
c'est la présence d'un conduit l'occiput
à l'unique donc condyle occipital unique
héron qui se distingue du condyle
occipital concave des des amphibiens les
amphibiens tacon deal occipital concave
c'est tout ce qu'on dit loppsi pital
vous pouvez le voir ici et convexes donc
mais ça c'est pareil c'est un caractère
primitif pour les âmes note donc c'est
un caractère que vous trouverez chez les
dinosaures par exemple que vous trouvez
chez les oiseaux que vous trouverez chez
les lézards les crocodiles tous
on a un candidat occipital unique et si
je vous le dis maintenant c'est bel et
bien parce que ce caractère est appelé à
changer dans le futur
enfin chez les espèces plus dérivés
néanmoins malgré la primitivité du crâne
on a quand même quelques caractères
dérivés et ses caractères des arrivées
ça va être la fusion des hauts postes
pariétaux donc les postes pariétaux que
vous voyez ici ils sont fusionnés ça
c'est le premier pas vers la disparition
en fait de la série post pariétal enfin
la simplification de la série post
pariétal donc encore c'est à dire c'est
un caractère qui la disparition
la série post pariétal en gros c'est
qu'à la fin on va finir avec juste le
supra occipital et tous les autres tous
les eaux vont être fusionnées aux supras
occipital donc on a le poste par l'état
le tabulaire elle supra temporal qui
vont disparaître et on va avoir aussi
une tendance à l'affût à la disparition
de la série cirque ou moby terre c'est à
dire là c'est la série d'os qui se
trouvent autour de leur [ __ ] vous avez
le préfrontal le post frontale et le
post orbitaire ainsi que le quadra taux
du gal qui se trouvent normalement ici
qu'ils vont finir par disparaître en
fait est un autre caractère dérivés ça
va être la simplification de la
mandibule donc la mandibule chez les ch
et les synappci d'aller primitivement
elle composée de cette hausse
au lieu de huit parce que il n'ya que
deux au chrono et donc vous voyez corps
ici c'est les eaux corneau il y en a il
y en a deux au lieu d'en avoir trois
comme chez les reptiles
donc il commence à y avoir une
simplification de la mandibule mais vous
pouvez voir que cette mandibules possède
quand même 20 de nombreux zoos et que et
que le dentaire
le dentaire est à peine visible sur la
face médial donc vous avez la face
latérale et ça c'est la face interne en
fait
donc vous voyez le dentaire sur la face
externe mais vous le voyez presque pas
du tout sur la face interne et en fait
ce dentaire qui porte les dents à la
base c'est pour ça qu'ils s'appellent le
dentaire va gagner de l'importance chez
les pélico szohr jusqu'à enfin chez les
synapses it pardon jusqu'à occuper la
totalité de la mâchoire et pas seulement
servir doses qui porte les dents comme
c'est le cas chez les ch et les pays
coordonnent chez les pays causeur le
dentaire est encore très réduit comparé
est-ce qu'on va avoir plus tard chez les
plus chez les ch et les synapses it +
dérivés donc ça c'est un petit petite
image juste pour vous montrer la
complexité de la dentition palatine donc
là vous avez la dentition près
maxillaire là vous avez la dentition
maxillaire c'est pas des dents palatine
par contre vous avez des dents sur les
veaux maire vous avez dans sur les
palatins vous avez des dents sur les
petits rigolos ide sur les procédures
sur les processus externe des petits
rigolos id ou latéraux des petits
rigolos ide et même des dents sur les
hectos pts et rigaud id
vous voyez que vous avez des dents
absolument partout sur le sur le palais
de ces pays causeur alors voici une
phylogénie simplifiée des pélico zor et
donc on va voir les majors groupe de
sept phylogénie donc cette phylogénie se
termine avec les fennecs ont une haute
idée mais comme je vous ai dit les faits
la cantine et vont directement donné
naissance aux thérapies donc c'est pas
la phylogénie total des pays causeur
évidemment il manque tout l'été rapide
et on va commencer du coup par les plus
bazot alors parmi les plus basses eaux
on va trouver les eaux fiacco dont idées
qui sont pas qu'ils sont parmi les plus
basses eaux mais aussi parmi les plus
anciens cynapsys puisqu'on y trouve
archéo thierry ce qui est le plus vieux
synap site qui datent du carbonifère
donc on le retrouve dans le carbonifère
décosse si mais si ma mémoire est exact
et donc archéo thirith vous voyez il a
il a juste ce qu'il faut pour être
considéré comme un synapses il à savoir
une petite fosse temporal et une canine
légèrement plus développé que les autres
voyez ici sur sur un autre au fiasco
dont ty cette toute petite canine mais
qui a néanmoins visible et vous voyez
qu'il ya aussi une canine sur la
enfin une canne uniforme devrais-je dire
c'est donc à une petite canini forme sur
la mâchoire inférieure qui est visible
de parle de par le fait qu' il ya cette
petite encoche qui sert justement
d'insertion à la canine inférieur quand
la bouche est fermé donc ça c'est les
eaux fiacco d'anti des le plus vieux
donc et archéo thirith mais vous avez
aussi donc au fiasco dont qui a donné
son nom à la famille quand vous voyez le
crâne ici alors le crâne à museau très
très long et des narines légèrement
rétracter ce qui a fait dire aux gens
qu'il est possible qu'il était
possiblement aquatique il ya aussi les
l'histologie osseuse qui semble indiquer
en fait que que les eaux fiacco dont
l'idée était plus ou moins plus ou moins
aquatique
alors ce qui est intéressant aussi avec
archéo thirith c'est qu'on a retrouvé
des fossiles avec des écailles
donc on a de très très beaux fossiles
préserver il ya de la pop réservées et 7
po et couverte des cayes écailles qui ne
sont d'ailleurs pas sans rappeler celle
de tiktaalik donc l'amphibien l'un des
plus vieux amphibiens donc on serait
vraiment sûr sur de l'animal à écailles
donc déjà c'est ce que je disais à
propos de à propos de justement les
généticiens et enfin toutes les théories
qu'on peut émettre à partir des animaux
modernes n'ont de valeur que si elles
sont confirmées par le fossile est en
fait on peut pas aller plus loin on peut
pas aller plus loin au niveau des
hypothèses que ce que les fossiles
indique c'est à dire que vous pouvez pas
faire l'hypothèse que tous les synapses
id avait des poils juste parce que les
mammifères modernes ont des poils c'est
pas possible il y à des fossiles qui
nous montre précisément le contraire
voilà les fossiles ce sont des points
d'ancrage de vos théories qui sont
solides et vous pouvez pas faire
n'importe quoi avec donc même si vous
pouvez émettre des hypothèses comme ci
comme ça il ya un moment où il faut se
tourner vers le fossile et regardez ce
que les fossiles nous disent et des fois
les fossiles ils nous disent des trucs
complètement contre intuitif comme les
premiers synapp ci l'avait en fait des
écailles voilà et ça ça participe aussi
au fait qu'on appelle c'est l'épée
dinosaures et les thérapies site des
reptiles malien c'est parce que
évidemment comme comme ils ont des
écailles comme il devait pondre des
oeufs bon on a un peu de mal à à ne pas
vouloir appeler ça des reptiles quoi
mais évidemment c'est avec des grosses
guillemets
tout ça un groupe de pays cause or qu'il
était très prolifique notamment en
europe et particulièrement en france
parce que j'ai en france on trouve donc
celui là alors ils s'appellent casey
arue tena sur cette figure mais en
réalité maintenant ils s'appellent
euromix ter rue tennis mais c'est
toujours la même question je veux dire
c'est toujours le même fossiles en
france on a trouvé euro/min a retenu ça
on a trouvé d'autres cas les idées et
alors les caser idées ils ont ils
montrent déjà les premiers signes de
spécialisation à l'herbe ivory donc
voilà on c'est un groupe qui apparaît
dès la fin du carbonifère et qui
disparaîtra au permien
arrivé au permien supérieur ils vont
survivre jusqu'aux permis à moyen et
donc c'est casey idées ils ont ils sont
très particuliers ils ont ils ont donc
cette espèce de crâne qui est très très
court et triangulaire avec un énorme
faux ramène pinéale une surface qui est
ponctué de plein de petits trous une
surfaceuse je veux dire qu'il est
ponctué de plein de petits trous ils ont
perdu vu qu'ils sont herbivores ils ont
complètement perdu là la présence de
canini forme
néanmoins si je reviens justement à
cette image ici vous pouvez voir qu'on
peut encore distingué une dentition près
canine même s'il ya plus de canines il
ya quand même une dentition prix max
hilaire et une dentition maxillaire qui
sont distinguables et surtout ce qui va
distinguer les cases et idc cette espèce
de de données extrêmement fins de
comment dire de région nasale
extrêmement grosse extrêmement épaisse
avec cette ouverture nasale très très
grosse aussi donc tout ça participe à
faire des cases et idées un groupe très
spécial est alors c'était un groupe
d'herbivores d'une part par son par sa
dentition mais aussi par son système
digestif vous voyez que la tête et
ridiculeusement petit par rapport au
reste du corps chez les caser idée voyez
les mains sont aussi ridiculeusement
grosse d'ailleurs la ceinture pectoral
et gigantesque ça rappelle un petit peu
les mots notres aime d'ailleurs vous
avez cette énorme un terreau clavicule
ici mais surtout ce qui impressionne
c'est la taille de la cavité de la
cavité thoracique et pourquoi pourquoi
est-elle si gros c'est bien parce que
c'était des arts vivants et qu'il
fallait qu'ils aient une énorme chambre
de fermentation pour digérer leur leur
nourriture extrêmement coriace
donc voilà les caser idée c'est vraiment
un groupe très particulier la petite
taille de la tête par rapport au corps
est aussi un caractère très très propre
aux cases et idées mais les caser idées
n'étaient pas les premiers ni enfin
n'étaient pas les seuls
herbivore les seuls synappci
d'herbivores et encore moins les
premiers les premiers synappci
d'herbivores les plus anciens ça a été
les états floride et qui sont apparus
légèrement avant les quinze lits d'ehpad
beaucoup en fait ils apparaissent dès la
fin du carbonifère comme les caser idée
sauf que les premiers casey idée était
carnivore en fait enfin ou du moins au
niveau or alors que les alors que les
heddaf autorités étaient déjà herbivores
au carbonifère supérieur donc c'est les
et d'affreuse au rider qui remporte la
palme des premiers synappci d'herbivores
eux mêmes n'étaient pas les premiers à
revivre terrestre puisque avant eux il
ya eu les dialectes omv qui était d d
des amphibiens reptiles huot morph voilà
donc on appelle ça des oueds des
amphibiens reptiles you more c'est à
dire que c'était pas encore des amniotes
enfin du moins ils ont pas encore
lessines apomorphine squelettiques des
amiotte mais ils ont déjà ils sont déjà
quelques caractéristiques mais voilà
c'était les dialectes il est direct aux
morts face qui étaient les premiers les
premiers herbivores terrestre du
carbonifère bref donc les heddaf aux
rides et vous les reconnaissez peut-être
à leur voile dorsale qui se distingue de
celle d'eudis métro dont parce qu'il ya
ces petites piques qui sortent sur les
côtés alors que 10 métro dont ne les a
pas on reconnaît aussi les dialectes
amorphe à leur dentition herbivores dont
vous pouvez voir que comme les caser
idées ils ont perdu la can uniforme mais
qui a toujours une différenciation
dentaire entre les dents maxillaire qui
sont plus plate et les dents et les
dents prêts maxillaire qui sont plus
cylindrique vous avez des dents palatine
extrêmement nombreuse qui servent à
écraser la nourriture et on reconnaît
aussi le crâne des états floride et
parce qu'il n'a pas cette forme
triangulaire comme celle qu'ont les
caser idées et ils ont cette espèce de
casque est en fait par dessus les yeux
ce qui s'appelle ici à knightsbridge
donc vous pouvez voir ici voilà sur
l'oeil
il ya une petite casquette qui se
développe ça rappelle un petit peu
d'ailleurs les si vous vous rappelez les
phoques les phoques avait aussi un peu
ce cette espèce de processus au dessus
de leurs beats qui faisait comme une
casquette au dessus des yeux
bon bah on retrouve ça et donc ça fait
aussi que la surface le dessus du crâne
des états floride est très très plat
voilà il est très très plat par contre
on conserve quand même cette espèce de
courbes qui caractérise si bien les pays
qu aux orres un groupe un groupe qui est
important chez les pays cause or parce
qu'il est déjà il a survécu la plupart
des pays causant n'ont vécu que au
permien inférieur et il ya quelques
exceptions qui ont tenu le choc
enfin la plupart des groupes de pays
cause hors apparaissent à la fin du
carbonifère et non ne survivent pas à la
fin du permien inférieures sauf deux
groupes les caser idées et les varano
pide varano pide ou varane oxydé vous
trouverez les deux mots
la littérature donc les varane au pid et
ça fait partie d'un des rares groupes
qui va tenir jusqu'aux permirent moyens
et s'éteindre avec l'arrivée du père
bien supérieure et dentelées varano pide
alors ils sont pas faciles
ils sont pas faciles à caractériser mais
ce qui va vraiment ce qui va vraiment
être intéressant avec les varano piles
et déjà c'est la présence justement de
ces ostéo derme
donc ils ont des os td ostéo derme le
long de la colonne vertébrale que vous
pouvez voir ici et les varane au pid et
on en a trouvé un exemple qui s'appelle
et leoz aux russes où on a un adulte qui
est accompagné de juvéniles d'au moins 1
2 3 4 juvénile donc ce qui pointe ce qui
tendrait à pointer vers peut-être
pourquoi pas un un début de soins
parental soit parental qu'on va
retrouver jusque chez les mammifères
et maintenant on va attaquer les fenaco
dont il est donc on a déjà fait le tour
vous voyez des cases et idées des
varannes oxydé des eaux fiacco d'authie
d'aidé et daf autorités on arrive au
sénat codante idée donc les semaines à
côte dans l'idée que comme je vous
disais sont les ancêtres directs des
thérapies side alors première chose à
noter à propos des faits n'a consenti
décès leur distribution
alors dans l'hémisphère nord d'abord
mais aussi et surtout dans ce qui
correspondait aux tropiques donc par
exemple on a on a des voiliers la france
ici la france était complètement sur
l'équateur et donc au niveau des niveaux
des régions tropicales qui couvrait la
france vous avez autun le gisement d'eau
tâche et qui où on trouve abstenus ce
qui est un qui est un aspect n'a codante
idée donc voilà déjà c'est la première
chose à remarquer c'est la distribution
purement tropicale despina qu une haute
idée qui peut avoir des implications
biologiques notamment sur l'évolution de
l'an doute terminée ou au contraire du
coup sur la non évolution de landau
termine celle et c'est là qu'on note id
mais on va voir que c'est très discutée
donc les semaines à cotiser on en
rencontre comme je le disais en france
on a obtenu ce mais on a aussi né au zoo
russe si je me rappelle bien donc né au
zoo russe cdc des animaux qui sont très
proches de 10 métro dont alors déjà
première chose à savoir c'est que dit
métro dont est pas du tout typique en
matière de senna codante idée puisque
déjà les semaines à cause anti
détiennent leur nom de ce fait à caudan
semaine à conan qui n'a pas de voile
dorsale donc déjà ça c'est un premier
caractère important à noter ensuite
qu'est ce qui va faire des semaines à
quotidien un groupe à part entière
comparé aux autres pélico zor et bien ça
va être d'une part le développement de
l'os dentaire dont klaus dentaire
s'étend vers l'arrière il commence à
s'étendre vers l'arrière
et ça c'est déjà un net progrès entre
guillemets net progrès vers la condition
mammalienne évidemment par rapport aux
autres pélico szohr on a aussi le
développement de ce qu'on appelle la
lame réfléchi deux langues eu l'air donc
l'âme réfléchi deux langues eu l'air
dont on parlera un petit peu après mais
ça c'est un caractère qui était pas
présent chez les autres pénicaud or vous
avez la réduction de l'offre lacrymal
donc rappelez-vous l'os lacrymal
s'étendait jusqu'aux jusque jusqu'aux
narines maintenant l'os lacrymal est
rétracté vous avez le maxillaire qui va
se développer pour devenir l'os dominant
de la face chez les pélico szohr la
fosse temporal reste primitivement assez
petit plus petite que la taille de leurs
beats comme vous pouvez voir ce qui va
caractériser les pélico szohr c'est
aussi un mode de vie prédateurs et j'ai
envie de dire prédateurs top prédateurs
quoi prédateurs dominant avec ses dents
typiquement crénelés à l'arrière comme
vous pouvez voir et enfin on a la forme
du maxillaire justement la forme de la
marge dentaire supérieur qui à cette
forme très sigmoïde qui est comme une
exagération de la forme qu'on avait vu
tout à l'heure
chez archéo thirith on se rappelle de
cette petite encoche là pour justement
faire place à la can i ni forme
inférieur qui vient s'insérer ici bon
bah là on a vraiment cette forme
sigmoïde très particulière qui est un
qui est un grand mystère on retrouve une
telle forme sinon sigmoïde aussi chez
les spinosaures idées et chez certains
poissons et on sait pas vraiment ce que
ça veut dire en fait alors justement le
on ne peut pas parler dit métro dont
sans parler de la fonction de la voilure
alors déjà avant de parler de discuter
de la fonction de la voilure il faut
savoir que la voilure dorsale c'est pas
du tout un caractère typique des
semaines à condom il est comme gelée dit
où les fennecs ont honte idée n'avait
pas de voilure et vous aviez différentes
salles ça
ça a taillé je vais y arriver il ya
l'anglais qui veut remonter
vous aviez différentes tailles de
voilure celle sp n'a consenti des mais
vous aviez aussi des espèces qui avait
pas de voilure du tout ensuite vous avez
les des zelda favori déchets qui
globalement tout le monde avait une
voilure
vous avez des technos pont deal qui
avait une voilure la voilure n'est pas
du tout typique chez et mvno sponville
mais il y avait au moins une espèce qui
en avait et puis après vous avez des
archosaures qui avait une voilure comme
lire certains raoult issue qu'un arizona
aux russes et vous avez évidemment des
certains dinosaures qui avait une
voilure les plus célèbres étant les
spinosaures et enfin les spins le
spinosaurus égyptiens cus et l'ornitho
pod ou rano aux russes donc d'ailleurs
tous les deux africains tous les deux
africains et tous les deux vivent dans
la moitié nord de l'afrique au crétacé
au crétacé donc ils sont ils sont
d'ailleurs plus ou moins contemporain et
ça ça fait ça soulève beaucoup de
questions pourquoi les deux seuls 10
node pourquoi pourquoi deux des
dinosaures ayant développé la plus la
plus bizarrement grande des voilures
dorsale ont vécu au même endroit au même
moment ça ça pose quand même des
questions mais donc là évidemment la
première fonction auquel on pense
la première fonction possible auquel on
pense quand on parle voir voile dorsale
de 10 métro dont c'est évidemment une
thermorégulation donc dit métro dont
maintiendrait sa voile perpendiculaires
aux rayons du soleil quand il veut se
réchauffer donc face aux rayons du
soleil et il maintiendrait sa maîtresse
à voile en gros parallèle aux rayons du
soleil pour qu'elle absorbe le moindre
rayonnement possible quand il voudrait
se refroidir donc c'est ce qui serait un
comportement qu'on s'attendrait à
trouver chez une espèce à sang froid
puisque puisque ils se serviraient donc
de la température extérieure pour se
réchauffer au se refroidir le problème
c'est que dit métro dont on a fait des
études basées sur la taille de
de l'orbité donc directement un ferrer
d'après enfin directement calculée non
pas d'après non pas d'après d'ailleurs
l'orbité osseuse pardon mais d'après la
noce clair aux tic donc on sait la
taille de l'oeil en fait qu'on n'a pas
la taille de leurs beats donc en en
faisant des études de la taille de
l'oeil grâce à la new school érotique et
bien on a pu se rendre compte que l'oeil
de 10 métro dont devait être assez grand
comparé à la taille de l'animal ce qui
est plutôt un caractère des espèces
nocturnes comme je vous rappelle la
taille la dimension des yeux chez les ch
et les tares scié par exemple un donc
donc on aurait éventuellement à l'animal
qui serait nocturne ou au moins qui vit
qui aurait été actif finalement en fin
de journée au soleil couchant ou lever
du soleil et ça du coup ça va pas
vraiment de pair avec l'hypothèse qui
serait que ça utile utilisait le soleil
pour se réchauffer grâce à sa voile
dorsale en plus on a des on a fait des
simulations justement de voile dorsale
est ce ça aurait été vraiment en fin
d'après les simulations la voile d'or ça
l'aurait été un moyen pas très très
efficace de se réchauffer ou de se
refroidir
chez dit métro dont donc et puis enfin
dernier dernière chose c'est qu'on a des
animaux aujourd'hui qu'ils ont des
voiles dorsale comme du métro dans donc
les basilic par exemple les basilic à
crête et ses voiles dorsale ne leur
servent pas se réchauffer ou à se
refroidir elles servent à la parade
amoureuse et vous pouvez voir d'ailleurs
que la femelle est absolument dépourvu
de crète alors que le mâle lui à des
crêtes
bon le truc c'est que dit métro dont on
en a suffisamment pour pouvoir faire des
analyses de dimorphisme sexuel et le
truc c'est qu'apparemment il ya le
dimorphisme sexuel est assez faible
celle du métro dont on aurait
effectivement deux populations de 10
métro dont giganteus l'un étant
légèrement plus grande que l'autre avec
une légèrement plus grande crainte que
l'autre mais les deux on décrète quoi
mâle et femelle 6 il s'agit bien de
mâles et femelles et pas de deux espèces
différentes mâle et femelle avait des
crêtes et enfin dernier argument qui
rentrent en ligne de compte donc je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure que lesdits
métro dont enfin que lesdits métro de ce
fait n'a consenti des avait une
distribution purement tropicale en tout
cas jusqu'à présent ce qui ce qui ce qui
soutiendrait un métabolisme à sang froid
puisque évidemment il ya que les
reptiles à sang froid qui sont qui sont
cantonnées aux espaces aux régions
tropicales mais on a enfin bakker a fait
ces fameuses analyse de population en
fait où il a mesuré la quantité
d'herbivores pour la quantité d'air de
carnivores il faut savoir que dans 1
un écosystème où dominé par les animaux
à sang chaud il y a très peu de
carnivores pour beaucoup d'herbivores
donc typiquement on a on a entre 1 et 10
lyon pour une centaine à un millier
d'antilopes dans un sas est un
écosystème à sang chaud mais dans un
écosystème à sang froid il y en a pas
beaucoup mais il y en a notamment les
systèmes dominé par les écosystèmes
dominé par les crocodiles
bah vous avez plusieurs centaines de
crocodile qui sont capables de survivre
sur quelques centaines voire quelques
milliers d'antilopes donc pour la même
quantité d'antilopes vous avez dix fois
plus de crocodile que de lyon et ça
c'est parce que les crocodiles sont à
sang froid et donc
et donc quand on regarde la quantité de
carnivores sur la quantité des
herbivores dans le registre fossile
quand on parle du canton par du permien
inférieur et qu'on compare au permis un
moyen donc le permis à inférieur c'est
là où on trouve les c'est là où l'on
trouve les pélico zor et le permis un
moyen c'est là où on trouve les
thérapies side est en fait les pays qu
aux orres ils ont une très très grande
quantité de carnivores pour la quantité
d'herbivores en fait donc on serait
plutôt sur du c'ur de l'écosystème à
sang froid et non pas à sang chaud
contrairement aux thérapeutiques chez
qui on trouve une très grande quantité
d'herbivores pour une très faible
quantité de carnivores donc vous voyez
là vous voyez normalement les la
diversité d'herbivores comparer
diversité de carnivores et là vous voyez
la diversité d'herbivores comparer
diversité de carnivores dont vous pouvez
voir qu'il ya beaucoup plus d'herbivores
au permis à moyens qu'il n'y en avait au
permien inférieur donc les écosystèmes à
ce fait n'a consenti d enfin les
écosystèmes dominé par les prédateurs se
fait d'un colon idée était apparemment
refus refléterait plus tôt
un écosystème à sang froid bon après il
faut rajouter à ça des billets de
fossilisation et tout ça donc ça c'est
un élément parmi tant d'autres il n'y a
pas de preuves évidemment donc il ya le
pour et le contre et on sait pas du tout
si il était à sang froid ou à sang chaud
en réalité laisse fenaco nanti d on le
saura probablement jamais l'histologie
osseuse indique que les fenaco dont idée
grandissait lentement qu'ils avaient des
cercles de croissance bien marquer ce
qui signifie qu'ils étaient donc pays
qui le terme ce qui est le contraire de
haut mais au terme donc le contraire de
ce qu'on trouve généralement chez les
animaux à sang chaud et les fenaco noms
et par contre on allait au fiacre
d'autres idées qui eux avaient n'ont pas
de cercles de croissance et qui avait
une croissance relativement rapide donc
les eaux fiacco d'autres idées qui sont
les plus bas taux parmi les plus basses
eaux des synapses id eux auraient eu un
métabolisme homéo terme ou alors ce
serait lié au fait qu'il vivait dans
l'eau et que l'eau à des assets
propriétés particulières qu'elles
conservent mieux la chaleur en fait
bref c'est un débat éternel et qu'on ne
résoudra pas en quelques clics
voilà croire qu'on peut résoudre ce
débat est déjà une d'une grande naïveté
donc voilà maintenant quelles sont les
caractères que c'est ce fait d'acompte
idée partage avec les avec les thérapies
donc les les synapses id plus évoluer le
grade supérieur j'ai envie de dire même
si en réalité
évidemment il n'y a pas de sommet à
l'évolution mais disons on va on va dans
global m'en aller dans la direction
qu'ils aient de moins d - mama liens
vers les plus malien donc notre
progression dans l'arbre phylogénétique
des des synapses id va choisir comme
sommet les mammifères
voilà donc on va considérer que les que
les
que les fennecs aux nantis laissons un
peu plus d arrivée du coup que les
autres délits cause or et alors qu'est
ce qui du coup les amène plus proche des
thérapies side c'est à dire le nôtre
notre prochaine diapos et bien ça va
être plusieurs choses déjà la canine est
plus grosse et ça ça sur la canne
uniforme et plus grosse donc se
distingue mieux d autres dents et il y
as cela se traduit sur le crâne par un
léger gonflement ici au niveau du
maxillaire qu'on n'a pas chez les autres
ce pays cause or on a aussi que les que
les dents sont enchâssés dans des bas
dans des enfin que les dents ont des
racines
donc elles sont enchâssés à l'intérieur
du maxillaire et dupré maxillaire ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant c'était pas le
cas chez les ch et les autres pays cosa
relais chez les autres pélico szohr il
n'y a pas de racines en fait les dents
sont juste posé sur l'os et il n'y a pas
finalement de racine et il n'ya pas non
plus de deux dalles v'eol dentaire voilà
c'est le mot que je cherchais il n'y a
pas d'alcool en fait donc si vous
trouvez un crâne si vous trouvez un
aspect un pélico szohr avec un avec des
alvéoles dentaire un bout de maxillaire
avec des alvéoles dentaire c'est ap
cette embellie cosworth fenaco dont
idées et ça c'est un caractère qu'on a
toujours aujourd'hui les mammifères ont
toujours des racines plantées dans des
alvéoles dentaire donc c'est une
condition qu'on appelle la déco dont 6
et qu'on retrouve justement chez les
ancêtres des dinosaures qu'on appelait
autrefois il était co dont tu d'ailleurs
donc c'est une évolution convergente
encore une fois on à la fameuse l'âme
réfléchi deux langues eu l'air donc la
lame réfléchi deux langues eu l'air ça a
l'air de rien comme ça mais celle été
rapide
elle est elle est là systématiquement et
s'éteint
en fait cette lame réfléchi deux langues
eu l'air deviendra là ça va devenir en
fait le teint panique donc cette petite
encoche là que vous voyez là va finir va
finir par soutenir la membrane du tympan
et en fait cette courbure va finir par
se courber tellement que ça va former
une caisse de résonance en fait donc la
courbure de la lame réfléchi deux
langues eu l'air va former eux plusieurs
millions d'années après 10 métro dont le
teint panique la bulletin panique on à
la perte du quadra taux de galles donc
cuadrado jus galles qui était présent
chez les ch et les pélico zorba zoo est
maintenant perdue donc ça fait partie de
cette simplification crânienne donc
maintenant le jus galles est l'unique
hausse qui forment l'arcade jus galles
et voilà donc le jus galles devient
l'unique hausse zygomatiques avec le
score aux halles c'est un caractère qui
est qui nous emmène vers les mammifères
puisque les mammifères donc pas non plus
de ce quadra taux de galles et donc
comme je vous le disais il ya un
dentaire très très long qui prend
possession on va dire 2
du processus corneau et donc il ya
réduction du nombre de corps au no id
aussi encore une fois je après le bon on
va voir ça après parce que j'ai mis une
phylogénie ici mais je reviendrai à
cette phylogénie après et on a toujours
comme chez comme celle epeli causeur
plus basoko mêler aux russes on a
toujours chez les fennecs aux nantis des
ces assemblages de juvéniles et
d'adultes en même temps fossilisés en
même temps qu'ils continuent de suggérer
la possibilité d'un de soins parental
donc celui là ça vient d'allemagne ses
pentes héloïse d'allemagne c'est très
très beau aussi une magnifique fossiles
on reconnaît bien là d'ailleurs le crâne
d'un spin off est la cause anti des 1 c
il n'y a pas de doute sur la partie les
affinités ce fait n'a consenti des deux
de ces animaux est donc maintenant on
attaque donc là je vais vous parler de
cette phylogénie maintenant donc on
attaque la transition entre les pays qu
aux orres les pélico zor et l'été rapide
donc comment se fait cette transition
entre les pays causeur a été rapide et
bien elle se fait par un intervalle de
nom fossilisation donc un gap qu'on
appelle le olson ce gap donc le gap de
olsson en fait c'est la limite entre le
sait plus ou moins en fait la limite
entre le permis à inférieur et le père
bien moyen donc on appelle le sirop le 6
sur un lien et le gwada loupien donc
c'est la limite entre le permis un moyen
espère bien inférieure en fait elle est
non fossilifère enfin c'est pas tout
simplement
c'est une question géographique en fait
c'est juste que le permis est inférieur
est représentée en amérique du nord
le permis un moyen est essentiellement
représentée en amérique du sud et en
russie en afrique du sud pardon et en
russie et entre les deux il n'y a rien
en fait y'a pas d'autres bassins qui est
enregistrée la transition entre le
permis est inférieur elle permet en
moyens donc quoique on va voir que
justement il ya possiblement un bassin
en chine qui pourrait donner
qui aurait de l'avenir éventuellement
donc donc on a mais on a quand même
quelques candidats possibles comme les
plus anciens terap side et possiblement
des animaux qui devait remplir le
l'intervalle d'olsson donc le premier de
ces animaux se serait tetra ceratops
d'amérique du nord alors tetra ceratops
c'est un animal un peu bizarre vous
pouvez voir qu'il a une lame réfléchi
deux langues eu l'air qui est un peu
plus courbé et donc un peu plus terrab
si diène que les laits pélico szohr plus
bazzo comme les cénacois nanti d vous
pouvez voir qu'il a des bosses sur le
nez ce qui est un lorsqu'il est un
caractère qu'on va retrouver chez les
biarrots soutien qui sont les plus
basses eaux d'été rapide et vous pouvez
voir qu'il a le
le los septs maxillaire qui est exposé
sur le côté latéral sur l'extérieur du
crâne et ça c'était un caractère qu'on
trouvait pas chez dit métro dont par
exemple vous voyez que le cepd au
maxillaire est à l'intérieur de la
narine ici alors que lâcher chez tetra
ceratops il est exposé sur le côté du
crâne et c'est un caractère par contre
qu'on va retrouver celle était rapide
donc donc pour tous ces caractères tetra
ceratops serait éventuellement un
thérapie side
après on a quelques problèmes avec cette
cette hypothèse la première c'est qu'il
n'a pas de canines tetra ceratops il a
de très grosses incisive mais il n'a pas
de canini forment en fait de plus tetra
ceratops il a un très grand lacrymal
voyez que le lacrymal il atteint l'os
septum axillaires ce qui en revient le
quasiment à lacrymal qui qui emporte
tout là toute la face en fait sur le
maxillaire donc le lacrymal qui gagne
sur le maxillaire c'est pas du tout un
caractère de deux semaines à caudan
idées ou de thé rapide et enfin et
surtout le problème de tetra ceratops
c'est que le fossile c'est chaud comme
il est c'est chaud comme il est pas beau
quoi
bon évidemment faut pas en demander trop
mais je veux dire déjà rien que pour
avoir comment ils ont fait pour
reconstituer ça veut dire quand vous
voyez l'arrière du crâne
moi je vois pas où il voit une fausse
temporal donc même à ce niveau là on
finit quasiment par se demander qu'est
ce qui vous fait croire que tetra
ceratops c1
c'est un petit cosséen synappci de quoi
alors si à la limite vous pouvez voir là
on voit quand même la lame angulaire la
mâchoire inférieure et pas trop
dégueulasse ça va mais pour tout le
reste
waouh il il est chaud à analyser ce
crâne il est très très chaud a analysé
donc voilà c'est pas du beau matériel et
les phylogénie récente et j'ai même
envie de dire à ce niveau là c'est de la
thèse qui a pas encore qui a été rendu
public
donc on a quand même le droit d'en
parler mais qui n'a pas encore été
publié défi de gêner récente place donc
les terres apside ici place laisse
pédago dont il est ici en groupe frère
des thérapies side et place tetra
ceratops à l'extérieur de tout ça donc
donc donc donc on n'a pas fini on n'a
pas fini d'en parler de tetra ceratops
parce que c'est très très controversée
et à côté de ça on a un autre candidat
pour remplir l'intervalle de olson voyez
il ya aussi que tetra ceratops vous
voyez les îles et du permien inférieurs
jusqu'à présent et ça n'a pas été remis
en question dont il remplit pas
l'intervalle de olsson par contre il y
aurait rares animus rares animus qui
vient donc du permien moyen de chine et
qui lui possède contrairement à tetra
ceratops une très très grosse canine
bien canini forme qui sépare bien
l'après dentition la dentition près
canine d'une dentition post canine on
pense qu'on a dentition post canine
préserver parce que comme vous pouvez le
voir c'est juste un museau on a comme
chez tetra ceratops une exposition de
l'os septum axillaires qui apparaît sur
le côté du crâne le maxillaire est bien
développée sur le côté
donc vous voyez ici la bordure du lac
rimal qui est là donc le maxillaire est
bien développée sur le côté
contrairement à tetra ceratops et du
coup et il est de la bonne date
comme je le disais pour remplir ce rôle
et les phylogénie récente le place comme
groupe frère ddt rapide contrairement à
des tracés rap-up ce donc a priori on se
dirigerait plutôt vers rares animus
comme plus anciens terrab site connu
tellement basale en fait qu'il
n'appartiendrait à aucun des six grands
groupes de thérapie site que nous allons
voir maintenant
donc on transition désormais sur les
terres apside alors quels sont les
caractères qui définissent les thérapies
déjà on va parler de la fosse temporal
la fosse temporal chez les pays qu aux
orres elle était toujours plus petit que
l'oeil chez les thérapies dont va
commencer à la voir s'agrandir le
premier le premier la première poussée
de croissance ayant lieu verticalement
donc vous pouvez voir que la fosse
temporal commence à s'agrandir dorsaux
ventre allemand ensuite on a une
simplification de la de la région cirque
ou morby terre avec une perte de l'os
post frontale au scandale dont klaus qui
se trouvait ici est une peste une perte
de loos alors supra temporal ce qui est
ce qui est pour le coup une
simplification de la région poste
pariétal donc le crâne continue de se
simplifier on à perte de dos en chemin
le cepd au maxillaire est exposée
latéralement c'est ce que vous voyez ici
le maxillaire domine la phase avec une
suture
tellement d'ailleurs qu'il en vient à
faire une future avec le frontal et vous
pouvez voir que le lacrymal du coup à
une extension faciale très limité et sur
la mandibule vous avez donc le dentaire
qui
qui est bien étendu et vous avez surtout
la lame réfléchi deux langues eu l'air
qui est maintenant bien formés très très
fine et recourbées un peu comme chez
tetra ceratops donc un des rares
caractère qui ferait de tetra ceratops
et intérêts un terreau apside alors et
aussi on à perte du joint intracrânien
donc de l'articulation intracrânienne
est complètement perdue ce qui va aller
de pair avec avec du coup la réduction
de la dentition sur le palais donc
généralement les dents qu'ils avaient
sur le pts et rigaud it sur les palets
sur les écoutes opté rigaud ide vont
avoir tendance à disparaître elles sont
elles ont déjà complètement disparu chez
les les dents hectos pts et rigaud ide
ont déjà complètement disparu chez un
ddt rapides les plus basses eaux qui
s'appelle bière mosuc us donc je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure que les bières me
soutient ce relais les plus banales les
plus base au pardon donc la dentition
palatine se réduit parce que ben a vu
que vous avez perte du joint
intracrânien vous ne pouvez plus vous
servir de votre palais pour tirer les
proies vers l'arrière donc c'est dans
palatine deviennent deviennent
redondantes deviennent inutiles le donc
je disais le dentaire et plus étendue
chez les thérapies site ce qui a pour
effet de la perte d'un autre os choroïde
donc il ne reste plus qu'un seul oscar
ono ida la base des thérapies des îles
vont être rap ce dernier roscoff chrono
il va être très très vite perdu et on a
simplification de la région pectoral
vous vous rappelez la région pectoral 2
de casey a enfin des cases et idées vous
voyez maintenant la région pectoral qui
est très beaucoup plus réduite et
beaucoup plus svelte alors vous avez
toujours à l'inter clavicule assez
balèze mais vous avez par contre perte
du clae it rome voilà il y avait un os 6
6 qui s'appelait le clae et roma l'a
vendu de la ceinture pectoral qui est
perdu est fusionné en fait au reste de
la de la ceinture pectoral notamment de
la scapula donc il ce donc voilà la
ceinture pectoral se diminue en taille
et se simplifient et vous avez
l'apparition d'un label à cet abus
l'homme bien profond sur le sur le
bassin qui est l'articulation avec le
fémur
donc ça ça va de pair avec l'évolution
d'une d'une posture qui était donc
complètement rampante chez les pélico
szohr donc encore une fois à caractère
très très reptilien vers une posture qui
est semi érigé celle été rapide alors
celle été rapide on va avoir une posture
qui va être semi érigé sur les membres
avant d'après ce qu'on peut voir de la
torsion du parce que le l'humérus et
légèrement tordu pour justement
s'articuler horizontalement avec la avec
la ceinture pectoral et s'articuler
verticalement avec le l'avant bras donc
il ya une légère torsion de l'humérus
cette torsion est beaucoup plus prononcé
chez les pays qu aux orres chez qu'il a
pour le coup on a vraiment une
articulation en angle droit quasiment 1
voilà donc la torsion la torsion de
l'humérus ainsi que la profondeur de la
fosse glen aux ide sur la ceinture
scapulaire indique une posture semi
érigé à l'avant et par contre la quasi
absence de torsion du fémur à l'arrière
la présence d'une belle tête
d'articulation et là c'est à bulles
sommes bien creusé sur les sur le bassin
montrent que les membres postérieurs eux
étaient complètement érigé donc se
diriger à l'avant et
complètement érigé à l'arrière donc je
vais revenir un peu en arrière voilà est
un des derniers caractères que les
thérapies side on qui est plus avancée
vers la condition mammalienne que les
fennecs aux nantis d c'est la réduction
du nombre de phalanges donc chez à ceux
chez s&p d'akono ty est en fait vous
avez une formule phalange yen qui est du
type 2 3 4 5 3 ce qui signifie qu'en
fait il il y a deux phalanges 3 phalange
4 phalange 5 phalanges et 3 phalange sur
le dernier doit on ne compte pas les
carpes ou létard ce bon ici il s'agit de
carpes parce qu'on regarde les mains
mais c'est pas important donc on compte
pas l'écart poule et ars
on compte que le nombre de phalanges
donc 3 4 2 3 4 5 3 chez les semaines à
condom idées ce qui est exactement ce
qu'on trouve chez les reptiles moderne
alors que celle été rapide
alors que chez les mammifères on a une
on a une formule phalange yal beaucoup
plus simple à retenir ses deux pour le
pousser puis en suisse et 3 3 3 3 pour
tous les autres voilà donc formule
phalange viennent beaucoup plus facile à
retenir pour les mammifères et donc ce
qu'on à celle été rapide en fait c'est
con on a une formule phalange yen qui
est toujours de type reptilienne c'est à
dire 2 3 4 5 3 oui mais les phalanges
les phalanges qu'il faudrait perdre pour
aller vers la foule morphologie
mammalienne sont déjà réduites chez
était rapide donc en fait vous avez 4
phalange sur le troisième doit mais il y
en a une qui est réduite donc
fonctionnellement et qui est quasiment
fusionner avec la première phalange donc
fonctionnellement vous n'avez que trois
phalanges et sur le doigt numéro 4 vous
avez vous avez donc deux phalanges
l'une est fusionné avec la première
phalange la deuxième est fusionné avec
la deuxième phalange donc elles sont
réduites et fusionnée aux phalanges les
plus proches
et donc c'est malgré le fait que vous
avez 5 phalange fonctionnellement ça
fonctionne comme 3 phalange donc en fait
on est quasiment formule fall orgyen de
3 3 3 3 voilà donc ça c'est un caractère
d'un petit peu plus avancé des thérapies
donc ça c'est la phylogénie des
thérapies telles que l'on l'acceptent
aujourd'hui
quand je dis tel qu'on l'acceptent
aujourd'hui ça veut éminemment dire que
il faut s'en méfier
elle est forte il ya fort à parier
qu'elle va bouger dans les années
futures celle-là elle date de 2001 c'est
pour vous dire mais on n'a pas fait
mieux depuis
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle un consensus
en terme technique c'est à dire que
c'est un consensus
oui mais on va pas lui accorder trop de
confiance voilà mais en gros on est plus
ou moins enfin les les
les paléontologues spécialistes sont
plus ou moins d'accord pour diviser les
thérapies dans en deux grands groupes il
y a le groupe des périodes honte chez
qui on va trouver donc les gorgones
obtient les terros efa liens et les
signaux dont donc globalement ce qu'on
pourrait appeler les carnivores
enfin les carnivores ou insectivores
parce que les signaux dont il ya des
insectivores beaucoup d'insectes yvan on
verra qui a même des herbivores chez 6
novembre mais bref vous avez donc les
thériault d'autres qui sont les laits
terrab sites qui sont le plus apparenté
aux mammifères parce que les mammifères
sont là voilà vous voyez qu'ils sont
profondément enracinées parmi les 6 no
doubt et vous avez les matériaux dont tu
qu'on va appeler les thérapies de base
aux c'est à dire qu'on sait pas trop où
ils vont se mettre cela mais ce qu'on ce
dont on est à peu près sûr c'est que
c'est pas des thériault d'hondt
voilà voilà l'idée donc parmi ces
groupes donc de thérapie de base eau on
va commencer par eux eh bien on va
trouver les bières mot soutien
possiblement les plus en les plus bas
the lady mais pas forcément les plus
anciens les dinos efa lien qui étaient
considérés comme les plus basses eaux
avant qu'on se rende compte que les
biarrots soutien existent et les anneaux
mode honte qu'il est qui compte
notamment les célèbres d'ici 90
alors commençons d'abord par les
biarrots se tient alors déjà ce qu'il
faut de la première chose qu'il faut
savoir avec les biarrots soutien comme
je disais c'est que c'est pas forcément
les plus anciens c'est pas parce que
c'est les plus basses eaux que c'est les
plus anciens on puisse qu'on a on
retrouve des fossiles dans le
milieu du permien au début enfin à
partir du milieu du permien même la fin
du milieu du père imam en fait c'est ce
que veut dire midlake père bien c'est
plutôt le late middle permien en réalité
qu'il faudrait dire d'ailleurs je vais
mal écrit ça mea culpa mais en tout cas
voilà les biards mossu cas c'est pas du
tout les premiers terap site voila on or
on l'a dit tout à l'heure le plus le
premier c'est rare animus mais on trouve
des dinos efa lien bien avant de trouver
les premiers bière me soutient voilà
c'est là aux jambes et les bières mosca
c'est un groupe qui est excellent et
excessivement rare on ne connaît pas
beaucoup beaucoup de spécimens on
connaît pas beaucoup de spécimens mais
c'est en train de changer avec des
découvertes récentes qui ont été faites
en zambie apparemment en zambie ils ont
des tetra chier de billard me soutient
ils savent plus quoi en faire
mais ça n'a pas encore été publié mais
il commence même à couper de dante
il commence à faire des coupes
histologiques dans les crânes tellement
ils en ont en zambie debiard mon soutien
mais bref là où je veux en venir c'est
que c'est un groupe qui a en tout cas
jusqu'à preuve
enfin jusqu'à présent étaient
excessivement rare est en fait la règle
chez les biarrots soutien c'était
quasiment à spécimens une espèce parce
qu'on n'en connaisse tellement peu qu en
fait chaque nouveau spécimen était
morphologiquement différent des
précédents et et voilà donc on a très
très peu de bière mon soutien on a une
prolifération taxonomique et est aussi
ce qu il faut savoir la dernière chose
qu'il faut vraiment savoir avec les
bières mon soutien c'est que c'est un
groupe qui a été reconnu que très
récemment il a été reconnu qu'en 1986
quand vous imaginez que la plupart des
groupes de
que déjà beaucoup des groupes de terra
psid ont été définis par ricciardo wayne
donc 19e siècle tintin temps
en vrille évidemment je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de faire ça à chaque fois que
je prononce le nom de ce mec
le vous avez la plupart des groupes de
thérapie sites qui ont été définis soit
par richard dow.n soit par broom
mais au début du 20e siècle mais voilà
donc au début du xxème depuis le début
du 20e siècle on avait reconnu aucun
grand groupe de thérapie side et pouf en
1986 vla un nouveau groupe les viarmes
au soutien qui était jusqu aux autres
autrefois place et donc qui agglomère
des espèces qui étaient autrefois placer
parmi les parmi les gorgones obtient et
vous pouvez voir qu'il ressemble un
petit peu au moins si on s'arrête là on
va dire et qu'on regarde que l'avant ça
ressemble un peu à un bourgogne tient
mais bon c'est tout ce qu'ils ont en
commun avec les gorgones obtient est un
des problèmes qu'on a avec les biarrots
soutien c'est qu'on sait pas trop s'ils
sont monofil éthique mais ça je vais y
revenir juste après donc les les
biarrots soutient vraiment typique ce
sont les bus on était amorphes et les
burnes était amorphe ils sont très
faciles à reconnaître
parce qu'ils ont une bosse sur le nez
deux bosses sur les au dessus des yeux
encore des bosses sur le square mozal
encore une paire de bosses sur le score
mozal est encore une paire de bosses
enfin sur le tabulaire pardon est encore
une paire de bosses ventrale sur le
score mozal donc vous avez 2-4-6 boss
voilà et des fois vous avez même des
bosses surnuméraires sur l'arcade
zygomatique donc deux une deux trois
paires de bosses plus une basse nasale
au milieu donc c'est des animaux qui
sont extrêmement bossu voilà et et ses
boss sont fait dos très très dense donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle la pac qui
haussent chose
voilà c'est on avait vu ça d'ailleurs
avec les on avait vu ça avec les cétacés
d'ailleurs comme je vous avais dit avec
les stations devraient en réalité parler
de [ __ ] ostéo sclérose parce qu'ils ne
sont pas seulement épais en fait pour un
os dans son diocèse sclérosé pour un os
et perd on dit pas qu'il y ait osmose et
là ils sont à la fois épais vu qu'il ya
des bosses et danse donc pas qu'ils
ostéo sclérose mais bon on va dire
paquet aux stones c'est déjà un mot
suffisamment compliqué comme ça
sachant que c'est rare qu'on ait des
eaux à la fois épais et badens voilà
chez les biarrots soutient donc on a un
petit problème de mono philly tout
simplement parce qu'en fait bien tous
les biarrots soutien non pas justement
toutes ces bosses les burnes et ya mort
font tous des bosses mais par contre si
je reviens au début je vous ai montré
bien beau succès alors bien monsieur cus
lui par contre il à la courbe
voyez la courbure du crâne qui est
typique des typiques des pays qu aux
ordres et qui est perdue du coucher les
biards mon soutien pu dériver comme les
burnes était amorphe du fait de la
présence de ces bosses donc c'est même
pas sûr en fait que ça forme un groupe
monofil éthique les bières monsieur k
parce qu'ils n'ont pas tous les mêmes
car enfin ils n'ont pas tous les
caractères dérivés qu'on retrouve chez
les burnes était amorphe et enfin une
dernière chose à savoir sur les bières
musique à la forme de l'oreille interne
est vraiment bizarre est extrêmement
bizarre et pas seulement enfin à
l'échelle de tous les synappci de
mammifères inclus elle est bizarre c'est
à dire que je considère pas l'oreille
interne d'une chauve-souris oudin
ou d'un cétacé particulièrement bizarre
comparé à l'oreille interne
d'habillement stuckey et sachant qu'on a
très très peu de matériel post crânienne
bière me soutient il serait pas
complètement exclu qu'ils aient vraiment
eu un mode de locomotion très très
particulier donc voilà on sait peu de
choses des biards mot soutien suivant
bombe à une chose qu'on sait par contre
c'est que comme je disais les burnes et
ya mort ont plein bosse sur la tête et
que ces bosses sur la tête on les
retrouve au chili aussi chez tetra
ceratops et qu'on les retrouve chez les
dinos et fabien et qu'on les retrouve
aussi souvent chez des sites d'ici 90 on
va en voir aussi des bosses sur la tête
chez les gorgones obtient et même chez
une espèce de terreau sefa lien qui
s'appelle queiroz aux russes donc il
semblerait qu'à voir des ornementations
crânienne quand c'est pas des canines
absolument surdimensionné avoir des
bosses et des cornes c'était apparemment
un grand classique celle été rapide et
donc on suppose que la sélection
sexuelle devait jouer un rôle important
chez les celle été rapide et a
probablement joué un rôle très important
comparé aux pélico szohr qui eux n'ont
jamais d'ornementation crânienne en fait
mais rappelez-vous que dit métro dont
utilisé peut-être sa voile dorsale pour
séduire les femelles donc il n'y est pas
il n'est pas exclu que déjà chez les
fennecs ont une haute idée on ait eu des
on a eu des parades sexuelles assez
sophistiqué mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'avec des ornementations
crânienne bahreïn ont fait pas de mon
fait pas tellement de la
thermorégulation
donc voilà là on est on est plutôt sur
une un rôle intraspécifique donc
peut-être des combats peut-être de la
reconnais de la reconnaissance de groupe
peut-être peut-être peut-être de juste
ce qu'on appelle du display c'est à dire
de la parade
on passe maintenant aux dinos et fall
donc on arrête avec les biarrots soutien
on passe directement aux dinos et fall
alors les dinos et fall contrairement
aux biards me soutient on les retrouve
au permis à moyen et uniquement au
permis un moyen donc ça en fait
d'ailleurs des fossiles très intéressant
du point de vue stratigraphique puisque
quand on trouve du ninon céphale on sait
qu'on est dans le permis à moyen et
comme on trouve du dino céphale on en
trouve beaucoup de dino ses fans en
afrique du sud
on en trouve beaucoup en russie donc on
sait que les dépôts sont à peu près 5
rhône mais on en trouve
on commence aussi à trouver du dino
céphale en amérique du sud et en chine
donc ça permet effectivement de faire
des belles corrélation entre différents
dépôts à travers le monde et donc ça
indique aussi une distribution globale
les dinos et fall sont très abondants et
leurs eaux sont extrêmement
reconnaissable puisque ils sont tous
parce qu'un pas qui est aux tic en fait
il n'y a pas que chez les dinos cephalon
va avoir le crâne qui est pâquis aux
states
[ __ ] ostéos whaou [ __ ] au sto tic ou pas
qui ostéo sclérotique c'est dur à
prononcer plusieurs fois d'affilée donc
on va avoir deux le crâne qui va être
pas qu' au sto tic mais on va aussi
avoir notamment celle et à pino qui est
validé
le squelette qui est pas qu iest et aux
pâquis au sto tic donc donc ça ça va
être des caractères ça va être des
choses importantes
donc ça les rend très abondant parce
qu'un homme qui au sto tic se préserve
bien et ça les rend
ça les rend abondant et ça les rend
aussi facile à reconnaître puisque on
sait de quoi on parle des comptes on
sait on sait ce qu'on regarde à chaque
fois qu'on trouve un os de dino ses fans
donc après les caractères qu'on va
retrouver de façon constante chez les
dinos et fall quelles que soient les
quelles que soient les groupes
ça va être donc les six napo morphy des
dinos et fall pour employer les termes
consacrés ça va être les narines qu'ils
sont en position non terminal donc les
narines sont légèrement rétracter vous
les voyez ici et là apparemment pas pour
accommoder une trompe parce que bon on a
pas de muscles pour ça il n'y a pas de
fausse particulière pour accueillir des
muscles donc peut-être que les narines
était juste rétracter et c'est tout de
ce fait beaucoup de gens pensent que les
dinos et fall notamment les plus massifs
comme mos cops était semi aquatique mais
bon c'est pas très convaincant les
isotopes sont pas tout à fait sont pas
tous d'accord
les coupes histologiques sont pas toutes
d'accord les et la morphologie générale
indique pas vraiment un animal
semi-aquatique donc bon débat en cours
là pour le coup c'est tout à fait en
cours il ya des ya encore des analyses
isotopiques qui sont faites aujourd'hui
qui devrait sortir dans pas longtemps
donc voilà on verra on verra ce que
l'avenir nous réserve donc premiers
caractères c'est la rétraction des
narines deuxième caractère est
certainement le plus important c'est
l'entrecroisement des canines donc vous
pouvez voir l'alternance en fait des
génies des canines des incisives
l'entrecroisement des incisives donc
vous pouvez voir qu'en fait les il ya
une alternance d'assises il vous voyez
incisive inférieur à 6 et supérieures
insidiae inférieur incisives supérieures
incisives supérieures incisive inférieur
incisives supérieures ainsi supérieur
inférieur supérieur inférieur bref voilà
il ya une alternance en fait quand la
bouche est fermée il ya une alternance
entre incisives supérieures et
inférieures qui est très très
caractéristique des dinos et fallières
vous voyez que ça fait ça leur donne un
sourire absolument terrifiant
les incisives d'ailleurs sont massives
comme vous pouvez le voir et donc à
l'intérieur des dinos cephalon il ya une
division en deux groupes des dinos et
fall le groupe d en teoz oriakhi sont
carnivores donc représenté parenté aux
russes d'afrique du sud ici et le groupe
d'états pineau kefaya qui sont
herbivores représenté ici par moscou et
donc vous voyez la dentition qui a perdu
notamment la canine donc tendance à la
halle au mode aussi qu'on avait déjà
retrouvé chez les cases et horia et chez
les ch et les états floride et donc les
hanter aux au rider ou entre les hanter
aux aurillac on appelait autrefois les
bris topia d'ailleurs sont caractérisés
du coup par leurs canines absolument
gigantesque leur incisive massive et
pointu donc une dentition de carnivores
une tendance à la perte ou à la
réduction des dents post canine vous
pouvez voir que les dents à l'arrière
des canines sont plutôt réduites
donc on est plutôt sur des animaux qui
devaient emballer des gros morceaux de
chair et les avaler tout rond et ça
c'est une tendance qu'on retrouvera chez
tous les terrains petit carnivore
d'ailleurs si vous vous rappelez bien on
a parlé des carnivores a donc les
mammifères carnivores à est pareil les
félidés donc les
les plus carnivore des carnivores à ont
tendance à perdre les dents qui ne sont
pas là carnassière donc on perd pas tout
les dents post canine mais par contre il
ya définitivement élimination des dents
surnuméraires une tendance à
l'élimination des dents surnuméraires
qu'on retrouvera chez les carnivores à
bien plus tard et chez les dinos et
fally a hanté au zoo rider donc chez les
carnivores
le crâne est relativement gracile
comparé à ce qu'on va voir après bon
c'est un crâne qui est massif
évidemment il ya une pâquis hostos
autour de l'orbité notamment mais en
fait cette pâquis aux choses elle est
limitée à la région orbitaire en fait il
n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas tellement de
[ __ ] hostos dans le reste du crâne ça ça
va être opposé justement aux dinos faya
tapis nos kefaya qui eux vont être donc
les herbivores qui eux vont avoir un
crâne paquet au sto tic absolument
massif est gigantesque et alors ce qu'on
va voir ce qu'on voit chez les hanter
osant aussi c'est une augmentation de la
taille de la de la fosse de la fosse
temporal donc vous vous rappelez la
fosse temporal qui était encore
relativement petit chez chez les
biarrots soutien voyelles la taille de
la fosse temporal chez les biarrots
soutien elles sont elles sont encore
très petit et bien chez les dinos et
fall et puis vous voyez ici chez moe
scops la fosse temporal est aussi très
petit mais non chez les hanter aux or là
on a une fausse temporal key est
gigantesque qui s'agrandit en hauteur en
largeur et qui s'étend d'ailleurs qui
est tellement grande qu'il ya elle
s'étend même en dessous de leurs beats
et ça c'est très typique des ventes et
aux orres la fouille corporelle qui
s'étend jusqu'en dessous de leurs beats
et encore une fois par opposition aux
tapis nos kefaya donc aux herbivores le
squelette est plutôt gracile bon autant
que vous puissiez ap les sags racines
mais comparé à moscou vous voyez le
squelette massif de mots scop cela on a
un squelette qui est plutôt qui est
plutôt légers on va dire
et donc les hanter aux or on en trouve
un peu partout on en retrouve en afrique
du sud mais on en retrouve aussi en
russie donc hémisphère nord et
hémisphère sud
que je sache on en n'a pas encore
retrouvé en europe
je crois et donc par opposition on a les
herbivores donc l'état pineau kefaya
dont l'un des membres les plus
emblématiques et les plus bizarres est
estimée nos excuses du permien de russie
donc vous restez meinau sucu ski à ces
espèces de protubérances sur le crâne
qui ressemble presque à d a des cornes
ou à des non pas des cordes m'aider
comment ça s'appelle des des bois de
cerfs voyez avec des ramifications et
tout ça donc et se termine au dessus qu
il ya vraiment une tronche quoi il a une
tronche bien particulière donc estimer
nos succès à des des andes et des tapis
noke fallait aller plus bas zoo donc et
vous pouvez voir que ceux restés meinau
succube déjà le déjà chez ce tapis noke
validé basale le squelette est massif on
a vraiment une ceinture scapulaire
gigantesque donc on a un animal avec des
eaux qui sont déjà extrêmement épais
extrêmement dense le crâne donc à des
ornements gigantesque aussi donc des
ornementations crânienne qu'on ne voyait
pas encore chez les hanter aux orres les
hanter hauser avait une petite bosse
supra orbitaire mais c'est tout là on
commence à avoir vraiment des crânes
commence à avoir des gueules quoi je les
tapis chez les titans de soutien chez
les tapis nos kefaya qui était autrefois
appelée laëtita nokia veut maintenant
faut les appeler tapine o'keefe à lire
et donc et qui va d'ailleurs les
ornementations crânienne qui vont et qui
vont avoir de cesse d'évoluer de ce
commentaire de pas de se perfectionner
mais de devenir de plus en plus
grotesque
au point que là vous voyez une
le couple fait avec un scanner sur un
crâne de moscou ops et donc sur ce crâne
vous pouvez voir ici
l'épaisseur dos comparé à la taille de
la boîte crânienne donc ça c'est la
taille du cerveau ici c'est la boîte
crânienne et ça tout ça c'est de l'os
donc on est sur 15 cm d'épaisseur d'os
par dessus la boîte crânienne c'est
absolument titanesque 1 c'est absolument
titanesque et d'ailleurs c'est pas pour
rien que ça s'appelle les dinos et falun
dino céphale ça veut dire tu est
terriblement grosse donc voilà pour le
coup ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire
voilà et donc de fait d'ailleurs de
cette pac est host aux deux du crâne
on va avoir tendance à la réduction de
la de la fosse temporal donc vous pouvez
voir qu'est ce tu aimais notion cus qui
est basale lui a encore une fausse
temporal relativement grande
mais on va avoir évidemment tendance à
la réduction de cette fausse temporal
jusqu'au point où elle va devenir très
très petit chez les tapis noces et
valider les goûts les plus dérivés donc
été mené au succès il se placerait là
quelque part quelque part à la base du
cloud et titane aussi kia et alors on va
avoir aussi chez les italo su qu'il ya
une tendance à l'homo dont six qui va
évoluer donc une tendance à la perte des
canines enfin la transformation des
canines endort mollahs reform quoi si
vous voulez et donc cette tendance à la
perte de la canine
elle est pas encore l ai pas encore
initié chez estée mais nos excuses donc
estimer nos succursales a encore une
canine bien développé d'ailleurs une
canine qui si vous regardez bien en fait
se trouve à l'extérieur de la mâchoire
tandis qu'à l'intérieur de la mâchoire
vous avez la rangée de dents poste
dentaire donc en fait il ya deux rangées
de dents chez estée meinau sucu si on a
une à l'extérieur qui comprend les
canines et les incisives et une à
l'intérieur qui comprend la qui comprend
les dents post canine donc c'est ça
c'est ce que vous voyez là en fait
voyez là la canine est là et vous voyez
là la ranger dans poste dentaire qui
commence ici en fait juste derrière la
canine
donc voilà ça ce sont les caractères qui
font de st meinau sucu ce malgré ces
ornementations crânienne grotesque
estime aussi qu est en fait un petit
anneau ce tapis nos kefaya basale
et on va retrouver aussi des
ornementations très développée chez un
autre tapis nos kefaya qui s'appelle
tenir à coke et phallus et qui lui aussi
à une canine justement ensuite on passe
alors avant de quitter ce temenos cus
juste un arrêt sur les possibles marque
de pau qui ont été fossilisé sur la
phase d'essai temenos focus d'envoyer
dans cette région du crâne
on a de la possible reste de peau est
alors cette peau elle est pleine de
petits globules voyait des nodules on
sait pas trop ce que c'est ray ce que
c'était des glandes est ce que c'était
de l'ornementation est-ce que c'était
des ostéo derme
on n'a aucune idée de ce que c'est donc
ce qui est adapté mais ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est que c'est pas des
écailles
par contre voilà donc estimer nos su qu
une des plus anciennes traces préserve
l'une des plus anciennes traces de peau
de terra psid donc du permis à moyen et
elle est dépourvue des cayes
donc maintenant on remonte un peu dans
l'arbre évolutif des dinos céphalées on
atteint les titane au suc idée donc les
petites annonces ou kid et dont le
représentant le plus emblématique et
zhang keyria très facile à reconnaître
grâce à son museau de canard au final
donc john key à re a encore une fausse
temporal relativement grande île là
encore une canine relativement
développée quoique plus réduite comparé
aux en teoz au rider zhang qian a
toujours pas de ne pas qu'ils haussent
choses extrêmement développé du crâne
donc dans beaucoup d'aspects en fait
john carrière ressemble beaucoup à
inventer aux orres sauf que il a un
caractère extrêmement important qui
s'appelle la morphologie talent n'est il
donc la mort feu
en fait les dents de jang cariat vous
voyez déjà qu'il conserve cette espèce
de
de de croiser entre dans supérieur
inférieur supérieur inférieur supérieur
inférieur donc les dents se croisent
encore quand la bouche est fermé et donc
sur les incisives zhang keyria a des
dents qui ont une pointe une cuisse pid
externe très développé et à l'intérieur
de la bouche en fait il y à ce petit
repli qui forment un bassin broyeur en
fait et vous voyez que donc le bassin
broyeur des est en fait en occlusion
avec la cus pid de la dent
de la dent du dessus et ainsi de suite
donc donc en fête dont les titane au
sulky des jo cariat font un pas en fait
vers la condition fortement herbivores
qu'on va retrouver chez les tapis notre
cfa l'idée parce que je vous ai dis donc
que l'état pinault qui est fall ya donc
ce cloud là était plutôt herbivores mais
en réalité on n'a pas tant de preuves
que ça que estimé nos su qu est ce tir à
coke et phallus était était herbivore
donc on on a trouvé des dents
possiblement ayant cette morphologie
lâcher ce tir à coke et phallus mais par
contre chez estée meinau circus c'est
extrêmement débattue
quelle était la morphologie dentaire de
cette bestiole là donc
donc c'est vraiment avec laetita noces
eu l'idée que pour la première fois on
voit des animaux qui ont une dentition
avec justement ce cette surface dentaire
cette surface dentaire ce bassin
écraseur qui fonctionne comme un marteau
pilon voilà qui fonctionne comme un
pilon et qui sert à écraser la fibre
végétale et donc avec les incisives
c'est ça qui est marrant en fait c'est
que c'est pas les matches c'est c'est
pas les dents post canine qui vont
servir à mâcher finalement mais c'est
les uns ça va être les incisives alors
mâché entre guillemets évidemment la
possibilité de mastiquer était très
réduite avec ça et de toute façon la
mastication je voulais dit c'est un
caractère de mammifères ces animaux
n'avaient pas du joual été rapide de
manière générale n'avait pas de jour où
on verra où les joueurs ont évolué et
ont commencé à permettre la mastication
plus tard voilà et donc cela nous amène
au groupe le plus dérivés oklad le plus
dérivés de
de tapis nos kefaya donc les herbivores
pur et dur l'étape inoki efa l'idée
qu'ils donnent donc leur nom oklad
d'état pineau qu'il fallait lire plus
grand donc l'état pinault qui est validé
ils sont ils ont de nombreux caractères
dérivés ils ont déjà le crâne qui est
fortement pas qui est aux tic vous
pouvez voir avec de très très forte
épaisseur d épaisseur osseuse et ils ont
une morphologie dentaire qui est
semblable à celle de john keyria sauf
qu'elle n'est pas seulement limité à la
dentition antérieures en fait les
canines vont se changer vont se
transformer vont se dés kaniz et on va
dire il ya eu nos maux dont six qui va
se former et en fait toutes les dents
des dents prêts canino dans post canine
vont acquérir la même morphologie avec
la talonnait morphologie donc le
marteau-pilon qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
chez john guérilla qui va se généraliser
en fait à tout la dentition donc une
dent vous voyez c'est dans massive et
fortement herbivores chez l'état pinault
qui est validée et du fait du
développement de la de la pac et aux
choses en fait vous avez aussi réduction
de
delafosse pour le muscle temporal donc
réduction de la fosse synappci d' chez
c'est à pino qui est validée alors le
plus basale de tous les tapis nos kéfa
l'idée c'est à pino canine us qui comme
son nom l'indiqué en fait est apte à
pino qui est validée avec une petite
canine encore donc la canine ne s'est
pas encore transformée en marteau pilon
chez papineau canine us mais il date
lieu alors ils datent du du permis un
moyen mais du début du permien moyens en
fait contrairement au tapis nos qui est
validée plus des arrivées mais vous
voyez qu'il a déjà ce crâne gigantesque
crâne gigantesque qui du coup qu'on
retrouve chez tous les tapis noces est
validée et qui devait servir à se cogner
violemment la tronche les uns sur les
autres alors ça c'est indiqué par pas
mal de caractère
l'insertion des muscles sur la face
postérieure du crâne indique donc que la
tête et est dans cette position ce qui
est confirmé aussi par l'orientation du
cerveau et de l'oreille interne dans le
crâne qui est qui indique donc que la
tête était naturellement tenu de cette
façon là et non pas de cette façon là
comme l'indiquent ce squelette monte à
l'american museum si je ne m'abuse ou
seo
c'est à chicago peut-être je ne sais
plus et en amérique quelque part mais
voilà c'est généralement la posture de
tête que vous voyez chez demos cops mais
en réalité devait plus se tenir sa tête
naturellement comme ça en fait et donc
voila voila a conservé sa tête au final
à l'épaisseur gigantesque de ceux de la
boîte crânienne devait servir à protéger
le cerveau qui se trouvait ici
donc voilà le choc arrive là se répand
sur le côté pour se dispersent sur le
côté pour passer par les bars post
orbitaire donc les bars post orbitaire
qui vous pouvez le voir sont très
épaisse
on est on est on est des bars post
orbitaire absolument gigantesque chez
tapine chez les mots scotch et l'état
pinault qui est validée et aussi par la
boîte crânienne parle par les pros tic
l'eau piste aux tic leur bitos pénurie
d'enfin tous ces eaux qui forment la
boîte crânienne ça se transmet
directement la faut savoir que la boîte
crânienne et pas du tout aussi fier chez
les autres terrab site c'est unique au
audineau ses fans une autre tendance
assez marrante a remarqué du coup chez
les dinos céphalées qui va de pair
justement avec la l'apa qui est l'appât
qui hostos du crad c'est qu'en fait les
espèces qui ont un crâne pas qui est aux
tic n'ont pas de canines
alors que les espèces qui ont le crâne
le moins patriotique sont celles qui ont
des canines et donc vous avez une
tendance à un déplacement en fait de la
fonction de combat depuis la canine qui
devait servir à se mettre sur la tronche
kid qui était peut-être sexuellement
demo refik jusqu'au tapis nocif à l'idée
donc qui ont eu pas de cannes uniforme
mais un gros crâne et ça ça reflète ce
qu'on avait vu déjà chez les ruminants
si vous vous rappelez notamment les
cervidés donc ça c'est une petite
tendance assez intéressante et après
donc comme je vous le disais les on a un
peu enfin les scientifiques notamment
par le passé ont eu un peu de mal à
croire que des animaux aussi massif et
pu porter le poids de leur corps sur
terre mais s'ils vivaient dans l'eau à
la manière de ces structures c'est
phallus vous imaginer qu'avec la tène à
la tête inclinée vers l'avant il avait
tout le temps le pif qui trempait donc
séparé là
le mode de vie de ces animaux c'est
encore un débat en cours en cours de ces
encore à débat en cours et il y a aussi
des analyses isotopiques qui vont
bientôt rentrer en ligne de compte dans
le débat
on arrive donc au groupe le plus
diversifié de thé rapide et ce groupe le
plus diversifié de thé rapide avec
plusieurs centaines d'espèces
ce sont les anneaux mode honte les
anneaux mode honte dans lesquels on va
retrouver les fameux 6 90 mais pas que
donc les signaux dont tu ce sont les
sons les l'été rapide avec un bec et des
défenses donc voilà la liste rose auris
vous voyez le bec et les défenses c'est
très typique des anneaux mode honte
enfin des dc 90 mais les d'ici 90 ne
sont pas les seuls à nos maux dont il y
a eu bien d'autres animaux dans tes
notamment certains qui reprend avec ea
qui agrandissent de façon considérable
la diversité de ce qu'on a de ce groupe
par exemple souligne à souligner à qui
était un anneau meudon et oui mais sans
bec sans défense et arboricoles
puisqu'il avait des griffes
enfin parce qu'ils avaient des pâtes
avec des longs doigts munis de griffe et
non pas de sabot comme les anneaux mode
hot plus dérivés comme les d'ici 90 par
exemple donc c'est certainement l'un des
groupes les plus
les plus prolifiques de terrab site qui
ait jamais vécu vous aviez des formes
arboricole des formes possiblement sur
semi aquatique des formes qui devait
avoir les membres plus ou moins graves y
porto c'est à dire plus ou moins en
colonne est gigantesque évidemment et 2
il ya par exemple l'iso vie fia qui a
été découvert il ya pas longtemps qu'ils
étaient là qui était possiblement un
anneau mode honte que qui devait peser
entre 5 et 9 tonnes donc voilà on est
sur un animal de la taille d'un éléphant
quoi on bon un bon gros dit gino d'hondt
de la taille d'un éléphant et puis vous
avez des animaux fouisseurs voilà comme
dicte aux dons dont on a retrouvé les
terriers d'ailleurs avec des petits
squelettes dans la chambre terminal du
terrier donc des terriers en forme
d'hélice d'ailleurs comme comme des
modèles x mais fait part des 10
innovantes et pas par des castors alors
on va utiliser cette phylogénie des
anneaux mode honte qui est pas forcément
la plus récente mais qui a au moins le
la bonne idée d'être clair parce que
comme je vous l'aï dit il ya des
centaines d'espèces d'animaux dont tu
rien que d'y synodaux en réalité c'est
le comme je l'aï dit le groupe qui a eu
le plus de succès évolutif il apparaît
au milieu du permien donc au permis aux
moyens et il ne va disparaître que à la
fin du trias donc c'est vraiment un
groupe qui a vécu très longtemps et il
ya même possiblement un anneau mode
honte qui aurait été enfin d'ici nos
dons qui ont été retrouvés en australie
au crétacé donc vous savez que
l'australie a servi de refuge pour pas
mal d espèces les marsupiaux et les mots
notres m par exemple
l'espé naudon ty et enfin les faits nos
dons idées qui sont en nouvelle-zélande
mais bon niveau écologique ça reste
l'océanie donc voilà c'est un endroit
refuge pour les pour les pour de
nombreuses espèces du mésozoïque on
retrouve encore aujourd'hui est bas et
il est possible que les dc nous dont tu
es sûr vécu là bas au moins jusqu'au
crétacé après ses très débattue il est
possible que cette dent en face ce reste
de 10,6 90 appartiennent en fait à un
crocodile mais bon voilà c'est ce jeu
repose là et vous en faites ce que vous
voulez donc on va attaquer d'abord par
les espèces basale dano mode honte qui
sont les anneaux mode honte non disent
innocente puisque lesdits synodaux tu ne
commences qu'ici voilà c'est tout ce
groupe là alors que les anneaux mode
honte non d'ici 90 voyez ils sont à la
base de l'arbre
donc les animaux d'autres n'ont dit si
nos déjà comment on comment on reconnaît
un anneau mode autres en général c'est
quoi les synapses murphy des anneaux me
dont tu es bien c'est très simple il y
en a il y en a trois
déjà il n'y a pas de ces rations sur les
dents donc rappelez-vous depuis les
faits dako d'anti des laisses fenaco
nanti d rappelez-vous les pélico sort
laisse fenaco noted et comme dit métro
dont avait des ces rations sur l'élan et
ses rations ont disparu chez les animaux
note d'ailleurs c'est à noter c'est que
systématiquement chez les ch et les
synapses id ce sont les groupes
carnivore qui vont donner les enfants
qui vont qui vont persister en fait ne
pas s'éteindre et donner les groupes
suivants donc chez les publics aux or ce
sont les carnivores semaine à côté dès
qu'ils donnent des terres apside chez
les thérapies site ce sont les
carnivores thériault dont six périodes
honte qui vont donner les sino dont tu
es chez les silos de ce sont les
carnivores pro b l'omnia tia qui vont
donner les mammifères
donc à chaque fois c'est en fait ce sont
des carnivores fin de des carnivores des
en tout cas des animaux qui survivent à
partir des protéines animales qui vont
qui vont avoir qui vont survivre en fait
et donner le groupe entre guillemets
suivant groupe paraphe il éthique
suivant à chaque fois à part pour les
mammifères
donc voilà c'est le succès évolutif en
fait des terres apside tient à la
protéine animale et c'est probablement
dû au fait que ce que le fuel de la vie
on va dire le fuel de la vis et les
insectes donc les insectes sont mangés
par des petit insectivore qui sont
ensuite mangés par les carnivores
voilà et les herbes ivory sait il est
très très dur de s'adapter à l'ère be
vori particulièrement quand on n'a pas
des dents très très différenciée et donc
et les terras piscines ne sont qu'au
début de leur différenciation dentaire
bon ceci dit on va on a déjà vu les
tapis ne kiffe alia qui avaient des
dents assez spécial avec le talonneur il
morphologie là on à le souligner a par
exemple qui a vouvoyé des dents massive
donc les animaux dont tu déjà c'est un
groupe qui nous ils sont tous herbivores
puisqu'ils ont perdu les séracs sion
dentaire c'est un groupe chez qui on va
systématiquement trouver une petite
fenêtre mandibulaire donc qui nous
rappelle un peu les archosaures
d'ailleurs petite fenêtre mandibulaire
qui certes d'insertion musculaire pour
les muscles mastic ateurs donc encore
une fois adaptation à l'herbe ivory et
c'est un gros pouvons avoir
l'arcade zygomatique donc l'arche
zygomatiques
va ne va plus être aligné avec la avec
la ce que vous voyez là donc la marge
inférieure du maxillaire donc la rangée
dentaire au final si vous prenez un si
vous prenez si vous prenez si vous
prenez par exemple
voilà là si vous prenez par exemple en
teoz aux russes vous voyez que l'arcade
zygomatique et complètement aligné avec
la marge inférieure du maxillaire et la
ranger dans terre voire même allé
légèrement plus basse
c'est pas le cas chez les animaux donc
chez les animaux nantes l'arcade
zygomatique et légèrement décalée vers
le haut et vous voyez qu'elle n'est pas
aligné avec la rangée dentaire ce
décalage vers le haut en fait et ça va
donner insertion à du muscle a encore
une fois c'est pour insérer du gros
muscles l'instigateur et ça va se
prononcer de plus en plus au fur et à
mesure qu'on va vers des espèces de plus
en plus dérivés
donc alors ici vous avez des exemples
donc là vous avez l'exemple d'un anneau
mode honte basale probablement à des
plus bas au d'ailleurs qui s'appelle
patran au mode ont donc pas trano menons
vous voyez qu'il n'a pas de défense
comme soumis n'ya d'ailleurs le
contrairement au dc no doubt les animaux
n'ont pas de défense donc soumis niall
voyez qu'il ya des grosses dents mais
pas de défense et vous voyez ensuite les
dc no2 typique qui eux vont avoir un mec
vont être complètement édenté et vont
avoir
mais bon quand même conservé une seule
paire de dans les canines qui vont
former les défenses alors maintenant il
ya des justement je voulais dit il ya la
chine qui commence à rentrer dans le
game du thé rapide et qui a produit des
spécimens intéressant notamment be
séries dance be séries dance qui
contrairement à ces anneaux mot donc là
à une canine développer et alors la
grande question c'est est-ce que cette
canine développer c'est la canine
ancestrale des thérapies side ou est ce
que c'est le premier pas vers le
développement d'une défense et pareil
pour l'amérique du sud en amérique du
sud a été découverte à ria jus dance qui
à cette gigantesque canine est alors
pour l'instant on pense que la canine de
tarja jus dance
c'est un développement secondaire qui
n'a rien à voir avec la défense des dc
90 est par contre la canine de bisser
riddance ce serait un caractère primitif
en fait la canine de base des thérapies
d'un qui serait retenu chez cet anneau
mode honte extrêmement basale donc donc
donc on aurait plusieurs événements de
perte et de réacquisition des canines
chez les animaux dont de base aux dons
qu'on n'est même pas encore chez lady
sino donc on parle déjà de perte et de
de pertes chez ces bêtes là et de
révolution des canines ch et aria jus
dance et chez dc l'eau dont tu es chez
lady synodaux de la canine donc ça c'est
déjà ça vous montre la complexité
formidable de l'origine et de
l'évolution de ce groupe
ensuite on a un nouvel événement de
perte de la canine qui a lieu chez les
ce qu'on appelle les drom à soria donc
les drom à aurillac qui sont le groupe
frère des véritables d'ici 90 les drom à
soria donc qu'ils partagent avec les
d'ici 90 la présence d'un bec mais qui
contrairement aux d'ici 90 n'ont pas de
canines voilà donc vous avez ici par
exemple galeote ce qui est le drôme à
soria typique on va dire et alors comme
comme lady synodaux je le disais ils ont
un bec et de fait là les deux symphyse
les deux mandibules en fait sont
fusionnés au niveau de la symphyse donc
ça c'est pas c'est pas galeote mais ça
vous montre ce phénomène de fusion de
l'aca fils pour former le bec et on a
aussi les mouvements de la mâchoire donc
vous voyez ici là que là que
l'articulation de la mâchoire maintenant
ce fait se fait bien en dessous du
niveau de la du maxillaire
donc là on à l'arcade jus galles qui est
soulevée finalement à ce niveau là mais
qui repart vers le bas pour donner
articulations à la mâchoire en dessous
du niveau du maxillaire
et cette articulation elle est allongée
en terro postérieurement
vous pouvez voir ici le conte deal qui
est aussi allongé en terro
postérieurement c'est comme les rongeurs
en fait les mouvements de la mâchoire
vont aller d'avant en arrière en fait et
plus et plus de bas en haut
donc on a un mouvement de propane
inhalent c'est exactement ce que c'est
exactement ce qui se passe aussi chez
les rongeurs du fait de la forme
cylindrique du condyle antero
postérieurement
ce qui nous amène donc aux véritables
d'ici 90 alors qu'est ce qui caractérise
les véritables d'ici volonté bien là
c'est la forme canonique du dc 90 c'est
à dire la présence d'un bec mais aussi
des défenses voilà donc le dessinant
d'autres le plus banal ceo dit synodaux
et on constate déjà qu'il a tous les
caractères des dix hinault d'autres
moderne à savoir donc ce bec les
défenses
un petit processus sur le côté de la
canine qui s'appelle le processus canini
forme donc la canine et au final elle
n'est pas toute seule elle est
recouverte par une petite langue osseuse
vers le bas qui s'appelle le processus
canini forme et on a un début de palets
secondaire alors le palais secondaire
qu'est ce que c'est c'est une extension
osseuse sur le palais qui sépare la
cavité de la bouche de la cavité nasale
donc ce palais secondaire en fait c'est
ce qui vous permet de mâcher sans que
votre bouffe vous sortent par le nez
voilà tout simplement
donc c'est ce que c'est ce que vous
touchez avec votre langue quand on vous
fait quand vous faites ça voilà donc
c'est ça le palais secondaire c'est le
fait le seul finalement le lot ce qui
vous permet de ne pas sortir votre
langue par votre nez voilà est donc ce
palais secondaire jusqu'à présent chez
tous les thés rapide et c'est tous les
pays causeur qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent
il n'y en avait pas
donc il était capable en fait de passer
leur langue à travers leur nez bon dans
la mesure où il n'avait pas une
séparation en tissus mous mais mais ça
on le saura jamais mais voilà donc il ya
un palais secondaires chez lady synodaux
et alors ça ça va être une tendance
qu'on va retrouver souvent chez les
thérapies de la formation d'un palais
secondaire mais mais à chaque fois de
façon différente et alors chez les 10 6
90 le palais secondaire il va être fait
par des prêts maxillaire et non pas par
le maxillaire comme on va avoir plus
tard chez d'autres groupes dont klaus
près maxillaires en fait va fermer la
qualité de la bouche mais parle de sous
voilà et c'est ce que vous voyez là et
alors le palais secondaire il est très
court chez audi sinon parce que c'est le
le dc no doubt le plus banal mais
évidemment va y avoir une tendance au
cours de la phylogénie à l'allongement
de ce palais secondaires chez lady
synodaux et enfin vous avez
l'articulation de la mandibule qui se
fait par deux condyle au lieu d'à donc
là vous avez un condyle médial et un
candide latéral donc une double
articulation de la mandibule qui va de
pair avec le
mastication propre à l'ina et dc le
héros dc nos dont il est juste un poil
plus primitif que les autres d'ici 90
parce qu'en fait le bec n'est pas encore
totalement fini de fait de la non fusion
des auprès maxillaire donc vous voyez
cette structure qui a entre les deux
côtés du bec
ici donc on a vu que la symphyse sur la
mandibule été fusionnées mais par contre
la symphyse sur la mandibule supérieur
sur la mâchoire supérieure n'est pas
encore fusionné en fait donc ensuite on
va avoir une tendance à la perte des
dents chez les dinos donc donc là avec
ses flèches vous voyez indiquer la
présence de dents chez les 10,6
d'audience chez les ch et les anneaux
mode honte donc de grosses dents en
rouge des grosses dents qui ne sont pas
relictuelle en rouge
donc vous vous envoyer chez les ch et
l'édition de vente mais aussi chez les
animaux note enfin devrais je dire chez
les animaux dont primitivement mais
aussi chez dc nos d'autres comme priest
euros donc que vous voyez là mais vous
avez aussi des dents relictuelle
particulièrement à la base de l'arbre
des dc 90 pas tellement chez les espèces
dérivés encore que il ya une espèce
tropicale tomas qui a des dents
relictuelle donc on a possiblement
réduction puis réapparition puis enfin
plusieurs occurrences d'apparitions et
de réduction des dents chez les 10 6 90
avec même certaines espèces qui voit la
réapparition de dents crénelés comme
chez les pélicans or en fait donc et aux
deux ans dont un an de tuyaux donc que
vous voyez ici avait le gros becs des dc
90 la voilà il n'y a pas de doute sur le
fait que ce truc est indécis 90 mais ils
avaient les dents crest de l'est et il
avait des batteries dentaire avec des
dents qui se renouvelait par ligne en
fait vous voyez d une ligne 2 ligne 3
lignes kathleen donc l'évolution des
dents
c'est pas simple chez dc 90 l'évolution
du dimorphisme sexuel c'est encore plus
marrant donc évidemment vous avez une
espèce vous avez un groupe chez qui vous
avez des grosses défenses alors le
premier truc que vous vous dites c'est
les défenses c'est un caractère sexuel
c'est comme chez les non classés des
canines donc ce serait comme chez les
phacochères ou chez les cochons quoi de
manière générale les mâles aurait des
plus grosses défenses que les femelles
ben c'est pas si évident que ça voilà
indiqué par une flèche rouge les groupes
chez qui on a pu mettre en évidence à
dimorphisme sexuel ce qui est ce qui
laisse tout le reste chez qui pour
l'instant
ben on n'a rien trouvé quoi donc là vous
avez un exemple de dimorphisme sexuel
démontré chez lady sino dont tu sais les
dicte aux dons donc dicté aux dons chez
qui on allait mal avec des défenses mais
pas les femelles donc vous voyez deux
fossiles à mal une femelle
vous avez des exemples d'adaptation aux
modes de vie fwi search et lady sino
d'onde donc notamment chez une famille
qui s'appelle les amis dopo id alors ne
l'a peut-être un ami de peau et que vous
connaissez c'est le kyste etc et phallus
donc qui signifie littéralement petite
tête de boîte parce que sa tête vous
voyez est très très large et carré en
fait vous voyez sont sa boîte crânienne
et larges écarts et est donc celle et
chez les amis dopo id on a évolution
d'une tête de plus en plus plate en fait
de plus en plus carrée réduction des de
la taille des yeux qui va avec
l'adaptation à un mode de vie fruit
soeur augmentation de l'insertion
musculaire sur la crête des lotos
pectoral de l'humérus donc augmentation
de la puissance pour creuser avec chez
qui ce téké phallus l'élargissement des
doigts comme celle et open aujourd'hui
si vous vous rappelez des taupes dorés
et des taupes normale dont on a parlé et
adaptation de l'oreille interne à
l'ecoute des fréquences sismique donc
les seules zones sonore qui parcourt le
sol au final donc cette cette forme
d'oreille interne très gonflée comme ça
très très globuleuses on ne la retrouve
aujourd'hui que chez les serpents
fouisseurs et chez d'autres espèces de
reptiles fouisseurs et vous voyez donc
ce gonflement progressif au fur et à
mesure qu'on progresse dans la
phylogénie des remises aux poètes donc
ce
donc on a une diversification aussi des
dédits synodaux qui ne commence comme
étant des herbivores finalement bas
de surface quad et zerbib basique un peu
comme des tortues puisqu'elles ont un
bel hedi synodaux tôt un bec donc on
pense à des tortues terrestres quoi des
herbivores comme des tortues terrestres
mais vous avez diversification avec des
espèces qui vont devenir fouisseuses et
alors je vais directement sauter à sept
diapos là et des espèces voyez cette
diversification va nous amener à ce
genre de diversité de morphologie
crânienne avec donc les espèces
fouisseuses mais aussi les espèces
qu'ils vont avoir un espèce de mufle
trianguler pas triangulaire
rectangulaire comme le mufle des
rhinocéros blancs et des espèces qui
vont avoir un mufle
enfin un museau qui va ressembler aux
muscles triangulaire des rhinocéros
noirs et rappelez-vous les rhinocéros
blancs basse et les tondeuses à gazon
avec leur muscle carré comme comme on
suppose l'été s'est dit si nos dont 6
alors que les alors que les rhinocéros
noirs ce sont les rhinocéros qui ont
aidé voilà un petit doigt délicat pour
aller sélectionner les feuilles qui les
intéresse dans les arbres donc ce sont
les mangeurs de feuilles les follivores
ce qui pouvait être le cas de ceux dits
sino d'hondt ci est évidemment vous avez
des formes intermédiaires
voilà donc à partir du donc là on était
milieu fin permien et à partir de la fin
du permien va se développer un nouveau
groupe de 10,6 nos dont tu donc on a vu
un petit peu tous eu tous ces dissidents
dont de base eau qui avait encore des
dents on a vu les eaux mise au po ide
qui se sont adaptés à la vue fouineuse
et donc ça chez lady synodaux tohid donc
les dix innovantes les plus dérivés et
bien là on va avoir vraiment super
adaptation à l'herbe ivory avec
l'allongement l'élongation du du palais
secondaires donc le palais secondaire
qui permet de mastiquer la nourriture
sans s'étouffer puisqu'on n'est pas
obligé de relever qu on peut respirer en
même temps qu'on match grâce au palais
secondaire puisque on a une vraie
séparation entre la cavité de la bouche
et la cavité nasale et bien ce palais
secondaire est une adaptation à la
mastication la mastication propre aline
halle et on va se diriger aussi vers des
animaux qui seront de plus grande taille
parce que les animaux de plus grande
taille ont aussi une plus grande
capacité à digérer la végétation
puisqu'ils ont une plus grosse chambre
de fermentation donc en fait c'est plus
facile de digérer la nourriture coriace
quand on est de grande taille est ok
après il va y avoir d'autres caractères
dérivés comme la perte de l'os octobre
terrygate sur le palais donc voilà pour
les 10 sinon d'auto idée donc c'est
parmi ces 10 synodaux torride qu'on va
trouver cette diversité justement de
de forme de bec plus ou moins
triangulaire ou plus ou moins carré
ledit synodaux tohid le plus connu c'est
bien sûr liste rose or use donc lisse
trop aux russes de la famille des listes
roseaux rider dont vous pouvez voir ici
le représentant le plus typique liste
rose aux russes c'est une famille de 10
si nos dons donc qui est très qui est
très connu qui est très atypique et ce
pour beaucoup de raisons déjà c'est
parce que morphologiquement ils sont
très reconnaissables à leur à la
morphologie du nez qui du museau
finalement qui est complètement tordus
vers le bas voyez donc contrairement à
ce qu'on peut voir chez indices hinault
dont deux classiques ou le crâne est
relativement plat en fait chez les 10
chez les listes rose aux russes le crâne
voyait il a cette torsion cet angle du
bec qui est très typique des listes rose
or idée qu'on trouve chez un délice trop
torride et les plus bazzo que kwazulu
zaurus ici donc la légère torsion du
museau qui est complètement vachement
plus prononcée chez liste rose aux
russes
on a aussi chez les histoires aux russes
une rétraction des narines et les yeux
qui sont projetés dorsale mans donc
projeté sur le dessus du crâne donc tout
cela faisant penser évidemment un mode
de vie aquatique possible avec les
narines rétracter pour être maintenu au
dessus de l'eau ainsi que les yeux sur
le sommet du crâne qui peuvent regarder
au dessus de l'eau pour cent que le tout
en gardant le reste du corps immergé
comme un hippopotame est lisse trop
russe il est aussi connu pour pas mal
d'autres raisons l'une d'entre elles
c'est pour être aussi un animal
fouisseurs alors le fait d'être semi
aquatique sea liste rose aux russes
étaient effectivement semi aquatique
le fait d'être semi aquatique est pas
complètement incompatible avec le fait
d'être un animal fouisseurs puisqu'il ya
des taupes comme la taupe année étoilé
qui sont à la fois qui nagent et
creusent très bien en même temps donc où
le desman des pyrénées plus proche de
chez nous d'ailleurs le desman des
pyrénées est aussi une taupe semi
aquatique
donc ce n'est pas un problème d'être
fouillée soeur et semi aquatique à la
fois donc peut-être que les listes rose
aux russes étaient les deux à la fois
donc là par exemple c'est un
la chambre terminal d'un terrier qui a
été découverte avec un bistrot aux
russes à l'intérieur et liste rose aux
russes il est connu pour être
extrêmement abondante ans au début du
trias donc c'est un c'est un groupe qui
a été qu'ils qui est apparu tout à la
fin c'est un groupe c'est un genre qui
est apparu tout à la fin du trias du
permien pardon juste avant la limite
permise trias donc la limite permise
trias vous la connaissez c'est la
fameuse limite péter celle qui à celle
qui a vu l'extinction de 90% des espèces
sur terre la plus la crise écologique la
plus grave qui ait jamais eu lieu sur
terre et donc beaucoup de thé rapides
ils vont y laisser leur peau
la quasi totalité des 10 6 no doubt vont
y laisser leur peau
sauf liste rose aux russes liste rose
aux russes il apparaît à la fin du
permien ici et vous voyez qu'il ya un
genre de liste rose aux russes qui
passent au travers de la crise une
espèce de liste rose aux russes qui
passent au travers de la crise disent
trop aux russes quand vas-tu c' est qu'
à côté de sabah au trias on a deux
espèces de liste rose aux russes qui
immédiatement après le trias vont se
développer donc liste roseaux et
évidemment ils vont avoir le monde
à eux tous seuls quoi voilà il ya qu un
seul genre y'a qu'une il ya qu un seul
autre genre de de dissin oddo qui passe
la crise permien trias c'est les eaux
mise au po id donc les amis de pau it
avec mignot zaurus voilà et c'est tout
donc
donc voilà les listes roseaux russe
c'est vraiment des espèces qui vont être
extrêmement abondante au début du trias
tellement abondante qu'en fait on va en
retrouver des restes dans toutes les
conditions taphonomie qu possibles et
imaginables avec inclut des momies donc
voilà une momie de liste rose aux russes
on voit le crâne ici et on voit la peau
momifié sur le crâne ici la peau momifié
autour des orbites donc les yeux sont
pas préservés mais la peau les paupières
sont préservés autour des orbites c'est
magnifique
regardez là le dos on voit les plis de
les replis de peau sur le dos c'est
merveilleux comme fossiles et donc ce
fossile n'a pas des cayes
mais il n'a pas de poils non plus donc
ça ça nous donne encore un indice sur
les origines de l'évolution des poils en
réalité c'est la dernière fois que je
vous parlerai de l'origine et de
l'évolution des poils puisque liste rose
au russe est donc le dernier exemple de
d'animal de thérapie site pour lequel on
a des traces de pau voilà donc ces
listes roseaux russe et liste rose or
use donc t'as pas de poils mais il n'a
pas des cayes donc on reconstitue
finalement l'histoire de l'évolution des
poils comme suit pélico szohr écailles
terap side peau nue et mammifères poil
et entre les deux sinon dont on aimerait
bien avoir des traces de sinnoh d'hondt
avec ou sans voile quoi un indice mais
on a pas chez les signaux sont donc
hélécine aux dons entre les deux c'est
point d'interrogation et donc liste rose
aux russes donc il est aussi connu
extrêmement célèbre pour être le seul
genre de dissin aux dons à traverser la
crise
permien trias donc à survivre la sueur
vivable crise permien trias et ça s'est
fait au prix en fait de sa taille donc
les listes rose aux russes du permien
sont très très gros comme liste rose
horus mât cay maca hi hi
c'est très difficile à prononcer mcafee
j mc liste rose auris makadji vous voyez
la barre d'échelle de
de 1 cm qui est tout petit donc à crâne
qui fait qu'il fait une bonne taille un
bon crâne qui vous faut vos deux bras
pour le soulever quoi et à côté de ça
vous avez liste rose aux russes des cli
vise donc de la crise
après la crise et lisse trop riche
murray après la crise oc ou là vous
voyez la barre d'échelle qui est
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus grande
comparée au crâne donc des crânes qui
tiennent dans la main maintenant
donc voila vous passer de deux bras pour
le soulever à un crâne qui tient dans la
main et avec liste rose aux russes qui
ont battu centre les deux qui est
qui est de taille moyenne et donc ça ça
s'appelle l'effet lilliput l'effet
lilliput c'est la réduction de taille
des espèces à travers les crises
d'extinction
c'est aussi un effet qui est documenté
pendant le ptm c'est à dire le maximum
thermique et aux éocène père paléocène
eocène qui marque la limite entre le
palais aux scènes et les eaux seine et
qui a vu aussi la réduction en taille
par exemple des équidés de l'époque
et puis après le après le trias à partir
du trias moyens en fête et au trias tard
et à la fin du trias vous avez un
nouveau groupe de 10,6 no doubt qui
apparaît qui semble être descendant de
liste rose aux russes parce que
autrement on sait pas trop d'où ils
viendraient et il s'agit des canes meyer
y former alors les 4 meilleurs et forme
ils sont très ils sont très très facile
à distinguer puisque ils ont le nasale
lawson l'os nasal qui est extrêmement
large parce que vous avez deux grosses
bosses sur les naseaux vous avez le
foramen pinéale qui au lieu d'être
située au milieu de la crête sagittale
est située à l'avant de la cré de sagy
talent et être en forme d'entonnoir
donc ça c'est très distinctive des canes
meyer y forme et vous avez les les
processus canini forme qui sont très
fortement développée
voire au point que chez certaines scheer
certain genre comme le très célèbre plat
sérias qui a figuré en bonne position à
la bbc en fait vous n'avez même plus de
canines en fait les canines sont
complètement remplacé par les processus
canini forme
donc voilà ça ce ne sont pas les canines
en fait c'est de l'os c'est l'os des
processus canini forme qui remplace les
canines donc et c'est ce que vous voyez
sur ce diagramme d'évolution des décades
meilleur effort mais pareil que celle
est en fête les 15 meilleurs réforme
l'avènement des cas de meyer et forme ça
va être aussi le renouveau en fait de la
diversité des dix innovante puisque et
bien les cannes il est calme et yari
forme pour avoir une énorme diversité
ils vont conquérir le monde de nouveau
pendant tout le trias et ils vont re
développer justement les adaptations
qu'on a vu chez lady synodaux tohid à
savoir fâcher les déchets les autres
disent inonde auto id du permien à
savoir un muscle car et celle et un bec
cas carré chez les
chez les formes [ __ ] et un bec à
bec plus pointus chez les formes qu'ils
mangeaient des feuilles
donc voila et on sait aussi que les cas
de mehiaoui forme devait vivre en groupe
parce qu'on a retrouvé des latrines
commune donc les latrines commune c'est
finalement c'est un gros tas de merde
c'est un gros tas de merde fossilisés
mais qui a été fait par plusieurs
individus
donc ce n'est pas qu'un gros tas de
merde c'est un tas de plein de merde et
ces latrines communes elles sont formées
aujourd'hui par les espèces qui vivent
en troupeau et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
pense que les calmes et yari forme il se
déplace en troupeau ou devrais-je dire
au moins ils fuyaient en troupeau c'est
le minimum qu'on peut dire donc ça y est
on en a fini avec les thérapies de base
aussi vous voulez aller faire une pause
c'est lé moment parce que là on va
attaquer le gros morceau de ce de cette
secours et le gros morceau ça va être
les thériault d'hondt les thériault
donne chez qui on va voir les gorgones
obtient les terros efa liens et les
signaux dont tu alors déjà quelles sont
les caractéristiques qu'on retrouve chez
tous les thériault d'onde quels sont les
signes à pau morphy détériorons alors il
s'agit d'espèces qui sont toutes
insectivores ou carnivores donc un
régime alimentaire qui est
essentiellement basé sur la protéine
animale
quand on regarde le crâne en vue
latérale le crâne de tout l'été rios
dont tu que ce soit les silos de
l'hétéro sefa lien ou les gorgones
obtient le crâne est plat
donc ça change de la de la morphologie
des pélico szohr ça change de la de la
morphologie du crâne très différente
qu'on avait chez les ch et les dc nos
dons et chez les et chez les
dino sefa lien par exemple où ils
avaient tous des crânes différents noms
là ils ont tous le même crâne et il est
tout plat voilà donc ça c'est c'est une
un trait typique des périodes honte
la fosse temporal est aussi très très
grande chez les périodes honte donc elle
est notamment étendu en terro
postérieurement pas seulement dorsaux
ventre allemands comme chez les
thérapies de base eau ou de façon de
façon bizarre comme elle l'était chez
les hanter aux orres avec cette
extension qui avait sous l'oeil ou de
façon bizarre comme elle l'était chez dc
90 avec ces espèces alors je n'ai pas
insisté dessus mais ça se voit tellement
que c'est pas la peine d'insister dessus
mais chez les dix suivantes vous voyez
il y avait sept grandes langues squames
aux halles qui se développe vers
l'arrière qu'on retrouve chez tous les 6
90 qui chez les 10 6 91 qui leur donne
cette forme de coeur quand ils sont vues
de dessus voilà donc l'extension de la
fosse temporal chez dc 90 elle avait
aussi elle était aussi en terro
postérieur mais beaucoup plus postérieur
qu'en intérieur en réalité alors que
chez les alors que chez les les
thériault dontla l'extension de la fosse
temporal se fait en terro
postérieurement mais de façon un peu
plus équilibré on va dire voilà et on va
et on va avoir une perte au total enfin
une réduction drastique voir une perte
totale de tout ce qui était dentition
palatine
bon ça c'est convergent avec les 10 ils
ont donc les 10 du monde on avait aussi
perdu leur dentition palatine mais elle
était encore très très prononcé chez les
anneaux modo de base eau notamment tahar
tiara jus dance qui avait d'énormes
dampt errigo id
donc on sait que c'est une évolution
parallèle en fait mais voilà à lécher
les périodes honte
contrairement aux biards mot soutient
par exemple les dents pas les dents du
palais vont avoir tendance vraiment à
disparaître et pas seulement être
réduite
voilà alors le premier groupe le groupe
le plus basale de thériault d'onde ce
sont les gorgones obtient donc les
gorgones obtient qui sont très faciles à
reconnaître de par leurs dents
leurs dents de sabre alors morphologie à
dents de sabre ce sont les carnivores
dominant du permien supérieur au permien
inférieure ce sont les terros efa liens
qu'on va avoir juste après qu'ils sont
les carnivores dominant mais eux ça va
être vraiment les carnivores dominion du
permien supérieur on n'en connaît pas
mal de fossiles
donc on est assez confiant dans les
caractères qui dans les choses qui les
caractérise alors la canine à dents de
sabre c'est évidemment à caractère de
gorgone obtient mais aussi vous voyez le
pré pariétal dont klaus près pariétal
participent toujours aux bords
antérieure du foramen pariétal chez les
terres apside saufs
enfin quand il est présent évidemment
quand lens prépare y est allé présent ce
qui n'est pas le cas chez les sea no
doubt par exemple mais quand il est
présent loos près pariétal et participe
toujours aux bords antérieure du foramen
pariétal sauf chez les gorgones obtient
chez qui il est réduit et en forme de
diamant donc voilà
cette forme du prêt pariétal et très
typique des gorgones obtient et aussi
quand on regarde le la face palatine des
gorgones obtient il n'y a pas de palais
secondaires contrairement aux dix
innovantes ou aussi 90 ou à beaucoup de
terreau céphale mais par contre on voit
le vo mer et le veau mais en fait il a
trois crête il a deux crêtes latérales
et une crête médial et ça c'est très
typique des gorgones obtient donc voilà
tous les caractères qui caractérise les
gorgones obtient après des caractères un
peu plus difficile à voir parce que ça
nécessite évidemment de voir les suture
sur le crâne c'est le fait que le jus
galles en fait ne participe pas à la
barre post orbitaire on voyait le jus
galilée tout plat quand on le voit en
vue latérale
parce que le poste orbitaire forme la
totalité de la barre post orbitaire ce
qui n'est pas le cas chez les autres
thérapies site chez les autres thérapies
side la barre post orbitaire est partagé
entre le gigal et le post orbitaire
justement mais là non c'est pas le cas
le jus galles est tout plat et le post
orbitaire forme la totalité de la barre
à l'arrière de l'orbiteur dont les
gorgones obtient on peut globalement les
classer en deux grands groupes
l'un des groupes et monofil éthique et
il s'agit du clad africains de gorgon
nokia et l'autre groupe n'est pas
monolithique et il s'agit du clad des
gorgones opia base eau etc il s'agit
notamment des spécimens russe de gorgone
obtient parmi lesquels figurent les
tresses le très célèbre hymne aux 30
c'est via voilà donc innocente c'est via
fait partie des gorgones obtient en fait
les plus bazot et alors comment les
distinctes on est bien c'est notamment
les proportions du crâne donc chez les
gorgones obtient base on va avoir un
museau relativement long comparé à
l'arrière du crâne
alors que chez les gorgones obtient
dérivés le museau est relativement court
comparé à l'arrière du crâne
les proportions sont plus équilibrés
entre l'avant et l'arrière du crâne et
la mâchoire inférieure est aussi
beaucoup plus développé vous avez
notamment cette ce menton en forme de
marteau qui devait qui devait être
terriblement puissant chez les gorgones
obtient africain qui est très classique
très typique du clad africaine gorgone
obtient alors qu'on ne retrouve pas chez
les gangs olympien on ne retrouve pas
chez tous les gorgones obtient russe ce
qui évidemment il va y avoir de l'effet
de l'évolution convergentes notamment
une hausse 30 c'est via qui va qui va
qui va évoluer de façon convergente avec
les le clad africaine gorgone obtient
aussi les gorgones obtient russes sont
généralement de petite taille sauf
innocent 36 via évidemment et vous avez
beaucoup de dents post canine parce que
chez les gorgones obtient il va y avoir
une réduction générale de une tendance à
la réduction des dents post canine qui
va culminer chez les rubis jean et donc
les gorgones obtient les plus dérivés
vous voyez là il reste plus qu'une
petite poignée dedans alors que je dans
le cloud russe est déjà guéri fausse
thomas n'a plus que trois dans post
canine donc le plus banal des gorgones
obtient africain n'a plus que trois dans
post canine comme ici ça c'est paris
fausse thomas mais c'est la même chose
que vous verriez sur un riff aus thomas
alors que les gorgones obtient russe
plus bazzo ont plus de dents ont plein
dedans post canine sauf innocent 36 via
parce que encore une fois il a évolué de
façon convergente
c'est ni plus ni moins que en fait une
une tendance à l'évolution d'un
une condition de prédateurs dominant en
fait c'est comme on avait vu de super
prédateur comme chez les félidés en fait
donc on a une tendance on a les mêmes
tendances que chez les félidés avec la
réduction de la réduction de la phase la
phase le museau qui devient plus court
la réduction de la dentition qui sert à
rien en gros et l'augmentation de la
puissance de la mâchoire et s'est donc
c'est tout ça c'est ça va évidemment
ensemble mais bon il ya 1 go nokia qui a
été découvert cette année je suis là je
suis pas peu fier de dire que c'est moi
qui les trouvaient alors moi et mon
collègue michael bay de londres qui
avons découvert ce gorgone obtient qui
est de taille assez remarquable et qui a
des dents post canine bien développé
alors qu'on la trouvait dans un dans des
dépôts relativement anciens très anciens
en fait comparer aux gorgone obtient aux
autres gorgones obtient africains donc
il est peut-être possible qu'en fait ce
schéma que je viens de vous montrer soit
change dans les années à venir avec
l'étude de ce nouveau spécimen qui n'est
pas encore totalement préparé donc
évidemment c'est pas pour demain
le temps de la recherche voilà on en
reparlera dans trois cinq voire même
disant ah si ça se trouve ça sera pas du
jour au lendemain évidemment et le
groupe le plus connu de gorgone bien ce
sont les rubis jean et puisque vous
connaissez tous cette image parce que
vous avez tous googlers extinction
permien trias au moins une fois dans
votre vie en tout cas si vous regardez
cette vidéo je pars du principe que vous
l'avez certainement fait si vous ne
l'avez pas fait faites le et vous verrez
que la première image qui sort dans
google images c'est ça donc vous
connaissez tous cette image et donc vous
connaissez tous dino gorgon qui est le
rugby jean est typique donc les rubis
jean est
nommée d'après ruby jay a donc ruby
djeha qui a lui-même été nommé d'après
la famille rugby jo qui est l'une des
grandes familles historiques de la
paléontologie en afrique du sud
et bien cette ses rubis jean est en fait
ils sont ce sont les gorgones obtient
les plus dérivés vous voyez qu'il ya
plus de dents post canine il yad'énormes
dents de sabre d'énormes incisive et
surtout vous voyez très développée à
l'arrière ce processus zygomatiques qui
va loin en dessous de la rangée dentaire
donc ce processus zygomatiques et très
typique des rubis jean et est lassé de
ces de la surface d'insertion pour les
muscles mastic ateurs qui ferme la
mâchoire comme je disais comme un
marteau se referme sur le pour briser
les os quoi et surtout chez les rubis
jean et vous avez au dessus des yeux
vous avez ces boss supra orbitaire
paquillo statique donc donc encore une
fois le retour de la pac et hostos
autour de l'orbité avec aussi à
l'arrière de leur [ __ ] vous voyez cette
barre post orbitaire très épaisse et
paquito tic une chose qu'on voit très
bien là sur ce spécimen de rugby jean
est et ça me fait penser que qu'il faut
que j'en parle
les rubis les gorgones obtient
généralement vont avoir une lame
réfléchi deux langues eu l'air sur
laquelle on va trouver un pattern en
forme de croix voyez vous voyez cette
forme de croix qui est légèrement plus
clair elle est très très bien visible
ici et c'est ce qui est alors c'est ce
qui est
plus ou moins représentée là mais c'est
pas très visible parce que là ils ont
fait qu'un seul trait à la croix en fait
donc ce n'est pas une croix c'est justin
une crête verticale mais l'a par exemple
sur le i nostrand c'est via là ça se
voit bien on a ce pattern en forme de
croix ici sur la lame réfléchi deux
langues eu l'air et ça c'est assez
typique des gorgones obtient aussi bon
la lame réfléchi deux langues eu l'air
étant rarement préserver de toute façon
c'est pas voilà vous voyez ici par
exemple c'est pas très bien préservés là
c'est très usés mais on voit aussi
vaguement la forme de croix il ya qu une
seule branche
en fait il ya que trois branches de la
croix qui sont préservés là mais voilà
ça c'est aussi très typique des gorgones
option et puis on monte un cran de plus
vers la condition mammalienne et on
atteint les périodes honte donc c'est
comme les thériault donc mais en vrai
voilà les périodes honte chez qui on va
trouver les terros et fall et les 6 90
est alors chez eux ce qu'on va avoir
c'est déjà le premier caractère ça va
être la perte complète des dents
palatine les gorgones nokia va encore
quelques dents palatine relictuelle je
pense qu'on peut en voir quelques unes
ici voilà vous voyez la face ventrale
il ya quelques dents palatine ici sur
les bosses voilà sur les bosses palatine
et qu'on voit aussi ici là sur les
bosses du palais donc ça c'est fini il y
en a plus chez les hôtes herriot d'hondt
il ya plus du tout dedans palatine donc
ça s'est très mal me faire on n'a plus
de dents sur le palais chez les
mammifères sur le palais aussi les les
eaux thériault dont tu dois avoir
tendance à développer un palais
secondaire mais contrairement aux dix
innovantes qui vont développer un palais
secondaire à partir du prêt maxillaire
chez les terros faya et les sino dont tu
le palais secondaire va se former à
partir de l'os maxillaire
donc c'est ce que vous voyez représenté
ici mais même chez eux
la tendance sera convergentes c'est à
dire que le palais secondaire va
passeport va pas se former chez tous les
terros faya et chez tous les signaux
dont les terreaux stéphanie à bazzo et
les signaux de base au nom pas de palais
secondaire et la façon dont le palais
secondaire se forme on va voir ça en
détail est différente
est ce que le vrai caractère qui va
vraiment
m kiki vraiment met tout le monde
d'accord sur la monofil idée d une
période entière c'est la présence d'une
crête sagittale crête sagittale qui
n'existe pas chez les gorgones obtient
ça c'est un crâne de gorgone pierre vous
voyez les fausses temporal sont grandes
mais elles sont pas suffisamment grande
pour se joindre au milieu du toit
crânien alors que chez les terros faya
et les 6 90 les crêtes sagittale les
fosses temporal sont si développé
qu'elle se joigne au milieu et qu'elle
compresse la boîte crânienne en crète
sagittale donc ça c'est vraiment un
caractère très typique des terreaux ses
fans et dessine au donc parmi les
périodes honte
est ce qu'on va voir aussi chez les ch
et les eaux thériault d'onde c'est un
développement de l'os qu'on appelle les
pipes perrigault id donc qui est un os
qui se trouve sur le côté de la boîte
crânienne alors il est présent depuis le
début chez tous les chais tout l'été
rapide mais j'en ai pas parlé parce
qu'en fait c'est un tout petit os très
très faim mais chez les hôtes herriot
d'hondt ce petit os très très faim
commence à s'étendre en terro
postérieurement il commence à s'étaler
voilà comme sûres comme du beurre sur
une tartine la tartine étant le cerveau
donc donc la tartine de cerveau se fait
étaler son petit beurre et peep terry
gaudi et peep toe rigaud indien est en
fait cette hausse deviendra ultime
mansle à l'isf et nos idées qui ferme la
boîte crânienne chez les mammifères
donc c'est un os qui n'a pas encore son
importance à ce niveau là mais qui
valent de venir chez les mets chez les
mammifères plus des arrivées mais en
attendant que cette alice benoït tu
termines de fermin et de fermer la boîte
crânienne vous voyez que le crâne
on voit au travers un sas et là il n'ya
pas de y'a pas d'artifices ici y'a si
vous mettez votre doigt dans l'oeil de
cette bestiole le doigt il passe au
travers et sort de l'autre côté 1
donc voilà tant que la liste benno ida
pas fermer la boîte crânienne lave le
cerveau
en fait il est fermé par du
par du cas il est protégé que par du
cartilage en fait ce qui est d'ailleurs
le cas chez les reptiles moderne voilà
et alors on va avoir une tendance aussi
à l'apparition d'un candide occipital
plus plus complexes j'ai envie de dire
plus différents c'est donc un conte deal
occipital qui au lieu d'être une seule
boule va être soit deux boules chez les
ch et les synodes honte donc un conte
deal occipital double ce qui est aussi
la condition qu'on trouve chez les
mammifères ou un candidat occipital en
forme de rein donc ou en forme de
haricot si vous préférez chez les terros
et fally a donc or il est généralement
admis que la condition celle été rossés
fall ya et primitive comparé à la
condition du double crocodile occipital
en fait c on est d'abord passé par une
phase réunis forment avant d'atteindre
la forme en double condyle donc avec une
séparation du goût du condyle réunis
forment par le milieu chez les 10 chez
les 6 90 mais on n'a pas encore trouvé
de d'espèces qui montre définitivement
ce phénomène pour l'instant donc
commençons par les terreaux seifalian
rapide tour d'horizon de la diversité
des terros faya alors déjà le truc le
plus important à savoir chez les terros
faya c'est qu'ils ont beau être plus
dérivés que les gorgones obtient il
était là alors il n'était pas là avant
les fossiles sont aussi vieux par contre
il était dominant avant donc en fait les
terros faya était très très gros au
permis un moyen et ont complètement
éclipsé les gorgones obtient du point de
vue diversité en tant que prédateur
dominant du permien moyens et c'est
seulement au permien supérieur que les
gorgones obtient vont prendre le pas sur
les terros efa lien donc juste après la
crise la mini crise d'extinction qui
sépare le
milieux le père bien moyen du permien
supérieur donc les gorgones obtient de
base était gigantesque et avaient des
dents de sabre aussi sauf que chez chez
sauf que chez les hétéros sefa liens non
j'ai dit les gorgones obtient ont été
rossés fayen les terros efa liens de
base était très grand et avait aussi des
dents de sabre sauf que chez les hétéros
sefa lien on a un compte de canines et
d'un sisyphe qui est beaucoup moins
fixes que chez les gorgones obtient chez
les gorgones obtient on a toujours 5
incisive et une seule canine à la fois
parce qu'après les incisives et les
canines se renouvelle toute la vie mais
il y en a jamais plus de d'une part par
alvéoles à la fois chez les terros et
fabien c'est pas le cas vous pouvez
avoir entre
entre 4 et 7 incisive et vous pouvez
avoir entre une et trois canine à la
fois et 3 canine à la fois je déconne
pas il ya une deux trois canine celui-là
il en a deux et c'est pas de l'invention
donc c'est assez balèze les hétéros sefa
lien de ce point de vue là est alors une
bonne façon de les reconnaître
déjà pour les distinguer des gorgones
obtient c'est évidemment la crête
sagittale mais une bonne façon de les
reconnaître c'est surtout la présence de
ces deux fenêtres sur le palais qui ne
sont présentes que celle été rossés fall
ya ait jamais ailleurs qui s'appelle les
fenêtres suborbital pourquoi parce que
si vous vous mettez votre doigt dans
cette fenêtre en fait il ressort dans le
par l'oeil
en fait et si vous rentrez votre doigt
par l'oeil vous finirez par trouver le
trou du palais donc de la fenêtre ce
support biterre on l'appelle aussi la
fenêtre et peep tes intérêts rigaud id
ou vacuité inter terry gou ide et
puisqu'il va les distinguer des gorgones
opiacés qu'ils ont pas le pattern en
forme de croix sur la lame réfléchi deux
langues eu l'air à la place ils ont ddd
petit rayon en fait des rayons au ceux
qui vont irradiés dans tous les sens
voilà un genre de soleil en fait
dessiner sur la lame réfléchi deux
langues eu l'air donc ça c'est ce qui
permet de les reconnaître très
facilement et contrairement au synode
honte ils vont avoir un tabulaire et
imposs frontale un os tabulaire impose
frontal très réduit mais qui seront là
alors que les signaux dont te vont
perdre le tabulaire est le post frontale
mais on verra ça après alors vous avez
différents groupes de gorgone obs de
terre au cfaa lien je vais y arriver
différents groupes qui dont on va parler
très rapidement mais en gros on va
commencer évidemment par les terros et
fabien bassot ce qui était le prédateur
dominant au milieu du permien au permis
un moyen donc à l'époque où le monde
était dominée par les dinos efa liens et
donc c'est seth et roser fanien ils ont
rien de particulier à part qui sont très
gros c'est à dire que ce sont des
terreaux sefa lien comme je viens de
vous les décrire sur la diapo d'avant il
ya un caractère constant en tout cas
c'est d'une part la grl la grande taille
et de deux la présence de trois à six
yves seulement sur la mandibule
inférieure
je vous ai dit le comte décisive a été
très variable chez les hétéros sefa lien
lecomte décisive supérieur est très
variable le nom lecomte décisive
inférieur semble être un peu moins un
peu moins variable voilà il semblerait
que trois incisives supérieures soit un
caractère qui soit constant chez ses
terres au cfaa lien bazot pourquoi je
dis terre au cfaa lien bazzo et pavlik
au sulky d'escale à cause au rider est
pris ce terreau guignette idée parce
qu'en réalité ces groupes sont très
probablement des groupes poubelles enfin
ce sont des groupes poubelles et donc le
la taxonomie est complètement à faire là
il n'y a pas de yahia rien à sauver au
niveau de la taxonomie de ces bestioles
là enfin il n'y a pas grand chose à
sauver au niveau de la taxonomie ces
bestioles là il ya vraiment tout à
revoir parce que parce qu'on s'est même
rendu compte alors pris ce terreau
ignatus par exemple il a une assemblée
de zone à son nom dont cristeros natus
c'est un gant c'est un terreau stefania
de grande taille et en fait on le pense
si typique du on le pensait tellement
typique de la partie supérieure du
permien moyens qu'en fait on lui a donné
une biozone à lui tout seul
et au final on s'est rendu compte en
révisant le matériel de terreau sefa
liens qu'ils étaient censés appartenir à
prester au ignatus en fait on s'est
rendu compte que au cas des spécimens de
priest héroïne hiatus qu'on trouvait
dans cette assemblée des zones denses
est bio zone n'appartenait réellement
appris ce taureau ignatus donc en fait
pris stéroïdes natus ne se trouve que
dans la zone at à pinos et phallus là où
on a trouvé le lot type
donc voilà à quel point c'est le bordel
je fais les gorgones obtient bazot c'est
tellement le bordel que qu'on a nommé
une biozone d'après un terreau ces
familles un basale qui n'est pas présent
dans cette besogne
voilà donc ses lacets voilà où on en est
donc je vais pas m'étendre trop mou trop
sur les terros et fabien bassot mais
voilà ils sont grands ils ont trois
incisives supérieures c'est les pc les
prédateurs dominant jusqu'à ce que les
gorgones obtient les remplacent au
permien supérieur et donc ont permis à
supérieur vous allez avoir l'apparition
de petit héros sefa liens qu'on appelle
les hôtes héros ses fans y en a qui sont
principalement insectivores mais on va
voir qu'il ya des exceptions et donc la
différence majeure des petites héros
sefa lien avec les gros terreau sefa
lien c'est la forme de la mandibule la
forme du dentaire donc vous voyez la
forme du dentaire le dentaire est très
très grand bon évidemment le dentaire ne
cesse de s'agrandir chez les ch est
l'hôte est rapide mais surtout il a pas
de processus angulaire voyez que la le
dentaire chez les terros et fali embalo
il a un petit processus angulaire donc
ici ce petit crochet qui s'articule avec
lang eu l'air là il n'y a pas de
processus angulaire donc ce qui donne en
fait c'était assez otero sefa lien une
mâchoire en forme de banane
voilà ils ont un dentaire en forme de
banane et ça marche très bien comme
caractère taxonomique je vous assure on
a du mal à y croire mais la la la la
banane la banane dentaire ça marche à
tous les coups
pour les auteurs australiens et ça
permet très facilement de reconnaître
ses torts au cfaa lien on a aussi un
autre caractère qui est que le rostre se
projette en avant de la ranger dentaire
c'est à dire que vous avez les incisives
qui sont là et en fait le nez ne
s'arrête pas aux incisives comme c'est
le cas chez la plupart des animaux comme
c'est le cas chez les terros et fanny un
base au nom le nez il continue après les
incisives donc ça leur donne un petit
rostro pointus comme ça qu'on voit très
bien sur ce cas l'opposent aux russes
par exemple
de manière générale comme je le disais
son plus petit et les crânes sont plus
gracile et la mandibule tentante à avoir
plus que 4 incisive
donc quand je dis 4 incisif c4 incisif
par demi mâchoire tout à l'heure j'ai
dit 3 incisive ils ont pas 3 incisive
ils ont trois incisive par 2000 mâchoire
donc ils ont trois paires d'incisives
les terros et fanny à bazzo et les et
les auteurs australiens eux ils ont
quatre paires d'incisives par demi
mâchoire évidemment qu'ils ont pas non
parce que j'imagine bien le gars en
train de se représenter à une bestiole
qui a 3 incisive dont une au milieu tu
vois non non non c'est pas ça
ces trois perdent incisive et donc les
auteurs australiens ils en ont au moins
quatre voire plus voire beaucoup plus
comme je les dis ça peut ça peut varier
donc le premier groupe qu'on va voir
deux hétéros céphale donc les otero
céphale des marlins et le premier groupe
ça va être les acquis dogan et ati des
acquis nos guides à ty et donc qu'ils
sont qui apparaissent au permien
supérieur mais qu'il man qui trouve le
moyen de survivre quand même jusqu'au
trille as donc ils passent la crise
permien trias même si on n'a pas de même
si on n'a pas de genre défini même si on
peut pas pointer du doigt une espèce en
particulier qui a traversé la crise
permien trias on sait qu'il ya encore
des acquis nos nati des au trias après
après comme vous le voyez un petit effet
lazare quand même hein ils disparaissent
pendant un moment avant de revenir sur
la scène donc cdc des carnivores qui
vont être enfin des carnivores des
insectivores qui vont être de taille
moyenne avec une espèce qui sera
relativement gros c'est qu'ils aient
moss coryne husse et alors ils sont
caractérisés par
c'est faux ce qu'on voit sur le palais
qui sont en forme justement de encore
une fois de rein ou de haricots
il ya beaucoup d'histoires de a ricoché
et eros et fabien voilà donc vous avez
cette fausse rennie forme qui est dû en
fait à l'élargissement du vo mer par
dessus la fosse qui est noeud censé
accueillir les canines et qui sert aussi
de deux narines interne donc les canines
inférieure se coince dans les narines
interne chez les terres ou sefa lien est
là pour le coup à cause du fait que le
veau mère est export est étendue
antérieurement
eh bien il n'y a plus la ca contre al en
fait la forme de ces fosses à une forme
réunis forment et ça c'est typique des
actinomycètes idées et le plus célèbre
détective n'augmente idée c'est le chant
bersia le champ vercia donc qui est
connu pour être le terreau seifalian le
terreau c'est fabien veine venimeux donc
pourquoi on dit qu'il est venimeuse
chambert siaba déjà c'est parce que son
crâne à des fausses sur le côté défaut
ce qui aurait pu accueillir une glande à
venin et surtout que les dents on sait
cette espèce de crête sur le côté que
vous voyez représenté sur la
reconstitution que vous voyez ici faite
par simplex paléo dont j'ai fait
l'interview ya pas longtemps donc allé
voir l'interview de 5 plex paléo aller
voir la chaîne de sim plex paléo ce
qu'il fait est grandiose et il est aussi
pâle et aux artistes comme vous pouvez
le voir et donc voyez ces crêtes qui
étaient là et dont on voit le voeu n'a
coulé en fait le long des crêtes parce
que les fosses dans lesquelles il y
aller il y aller la glande à venin
supposer qu'ils sont rouges rougeâtre
ici sont connectés aux canines par des
petits canaux qu'on a réussi à voir sur
les scanners en fait donc voilà donc
youtube garcia c'est vraiment un animal
très très atypique très très spécial qui
a vécu au permien supérieur et
et qui est très mystérieux parce qu'on
en a que deux spécimens alors vous
pouvez voir aussi youtube et recel il a
ce museau très épais et il n'a pas de
dents post canine donc c'était un
carnivore
c'était un carnivore mais par contre le
crâne tient dans la main donc ce n'était
pas un gros carnivores c'était un
carnivore moyens on va dire et donc le
propre le plus proche cousin de hugh
chambers la semos corinus emos coryne
husse baïla comme auchan bersia il a
cette espèce de deux museaux extrêmement
épais extrêmement large comme youtube
bersia les dents post canines ont
disparu alors presque disparu chez moss
corps à nu s'il en reste
il reste quelques dents relictuelle
alors que chez urgent bersia y en a plus
et après une différence notable avec le
chant bersia c'est la présence d'un faux
ramène pinéale alors que charley auchan
berciaud n'en n'a pas et aussi vous
voyez moscow jaén us à ces fausses
interséries go id bien nets alors que de
chants bersia les a perdus donc voilà
les différences mais sinon moss corinne
eu ces chants bersia ont cette
particularité d'avoir le museau très
large et moss coryne husse est connue
aussi pour être le
interros sefa lien qui a traversé la
crise permien trias il n'a pas traversé
pendant longtemps il est mort quasiment
juste après mais pendant la crise
permien trias moss coryne husse survie
et saas et voilà ça fait de lui la
deuxième le deuxième taxons à le faire
avec liste rose aux russes voilà donc
c'est pas négligeable et ça se voit
voyez ici vous avez la crise permien
trias marqué par ce trait noir moss
coryne husse qui est là pendant le
permis est supérieure et un est quand
même et il parvient à arriver au début
du trias mais pas pendant longtemps donc
l'autre groupe de terreau céphale ce
sont les un autre groupe de terreau
céphale ce sont les white side et donc
les whites idées dont le le représentant
typique et thériault ignatus thériault
mena tuschi efforts reconnaissable à son
museau très fin qui s'associe avec
l'absence totale encore une fois dedans
post canine donc c'est comme ayew
tschamber sia ou comme un moss corinus
mais avec le museau très fin voilà et on
a aussi le d'autres caractères et
notamment la formation d'un début de
palets secondaire ici qui commence à se
former donc y aller les maxillaires en
fait qu'ils envoient des deux crêtes qui
sur lesquels devaient être tendu un
palais secondaire mais en tissus mous
peut-être en cartilage
vous voyez ces deux crêtes commencent à
fermer un palais secondaire et vous
voyez le vo mer aussi le vo mer ici qui
forment un palais secondaire entre les
deux maxillaire et les prêts maxillaire
donc en fait vous avez ici la fosse pour
les canines et rappelez-vous chez ocz en
bersia la fosse pour les canines été
fusionnées aux narines interne mais pas
chez thériault snatch et héros de natus
il ya une fausse pour les canines et une
fosse pour les narines secondaire avec
un vrai pas les secondaires entre les
deux voilà donc c'est ça le palais
secondaire et comme vous pouvez le voir
du coup ce palais secondaire est d'abord
formé par les veaux mer ce qui ne sera
pas le cas chez les sino donc chez les
sino donc le palais secondaire sera
formée uniquement par les maxillaires et
pas du tout parler vos mères dans ce cas
là les thériault de natus a cette
particularité aussi d'avoir perdu les
les vacuités su suborbital alors c'est
évidemment je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
les vacuités suborbital c'est typique
des terreaux céphale là je vous montre
des exemples qui sont facilement
reconnaissables donc les
hugh chambers sia hugh chambers siae
thériault et natus sont facilement
reconnaissable parmi les terros et fall
précisément parce qu'ils perdent c'est
vacuité suborbital donc mais ne faut pas
perdre de vue que les vacuités
suborbital sont présentes chez tous les
autres terreau ses fans
évidemment c'est je vous montre les cas
atypique
justement parce qu'ils sont atypiques et
le dernier groupe est le plus celui avec
le plus grand succès évolutif de terreau
céphale c'est les bords rio id donc
encore une fois un groupe qui va passer
la limite permise trias mais avec
beaucoup plus de succès que les acquis
nominated et avec tetra synodaux qui va
même survivre à la crise permien trias
donc autant pour moi il n'y a pas que
moss coryne husse ya aussi tetra
synodaux qui passe à travers la crise le
permien trias donc là toutes les espèces
ou presque sont de petite taille sont
des insectivores à part à part les
espèces qui a donné son nom au groupe
borias qui a des dents très large et des
dents molaires quasiment on pourrait
dire parce que là c'est les post canines
sont très très larges et sont en
occlusion pour broyer delà des fibres
végétales
donc on est en efface finalement un
herbivore avec bord ya donc le borias
qui a donné son nom au clac finalement
est un très mauvais exemple puisque il
n'est pas insectivores il est herbivore
mais voilà c'est aussi ce que je vous
disais je vous montre pas forcément les
cas les plus les plus typiques mais on a
en même temps on n'est pas aidés là
c'est le nom du groupe qui est basée sur
l'espèce la moins typique du groupe au
final donc généralement les bords you i
dont un très long rostre ils ont thakran
plutôt gracile avec une absence de bach
post orbitaire donc la barre post
orbitaire est généralement perdu et
alors sur tout ce qui ce qu'on trouve
chez les boys aux ide
c'est un palais secondaire totalement
formés et dans lequel le vo mer ne
participe plus donc ça le vaut mer c'est
bon c'est fini on enlève le maxillaire a
complètement remplacé le vo mer et vous
pouvez voir que les kohan donc les
narines internes sont repoussés vers
l'arrière elles ne sont plus sur le bord
de
la bouche ici elles sont bien repoussés
vers l'arrière par le palais secondaire
qui sépare complètement la qualité
buccale de la cavité nasale
donc voilà comment on n'atteint pas les
secondaires vous avez la condition chez
ocz en bersia ou les fausses canine et
les coen sont fusionnés vous avez la
condition chez thériault et natus ou les
fausses canines sont séparés d'écho and
par le veau mer et petit à petit en fait
les maxillaires vont se développer
autour du veau mère pousser les kohan
vers l'arrière et finir par remplacer
les veaux mère complètement au milieu du
palais secondaire et à la fin vous avez
même une petite participation des prix
maxi d'air c'est vous dire
et voilà donc les fameux les fameux bord
hyoïde herbivores borias et son petit
cousin microg au fond dont la différence
entre les deux étant boriana pas deux
fois ramène pas pinéale alors que
microbes aux fourneaux à un foramen
pinéale donc microg au fond nous renvoie
directement à ce qu'on appelle la
dentition go fondante c'est à dire la
dentition les dents post canine qui sont
larges
rappelez-vous de gontaud terium
d'ailleurs gonfo terium qui était le
provost cydia qui était un propos si
bien et qu'ils avaient des dents pareil
très très larges très épaisse bombe à la
microseconde fond d'eau et bords ya ils
ont aussi des dents gong fu d'hôtes
c'est à dire des dents qui sont très
très large et en occlusion et enfin last
but not least les synodes honte alors
les sino d'onde c'est le groupe qui a
donné naissance aux mammifères
mammifères que vous voyez ici le clad
mallya
les voilà enfin pointer le bout de leur
nez les mammifères et alors là vous
voyez que dans cet arbre phylogénétique
des 6 90
les mammifères sont très profondément
enraciné donc les mammifères sont
profondément dessine aux dons donc là je
vais vous parler des synodes honte non
malien mais il faut pas oublier que les
synodaux que les mammifères font partie
éminemment partie des synodes honte
donc on va quand on va diviser les
synodaux temps trois groupes pour pour
la simplicité on va dire on va parler
des signaux de base aux donc c'est à
dire les espèces qui sont ici en rouge
et en orange on va parler des synodes on
tend vers ici qui sont les sino gagne at
et on va parler des signaux d'onde qui
sont en bleu
ici qui sont les pro b nonya tu donc
déjà qu'est ce qui caractérise les
synodaux quels sont les signes
apomorphine et 6,90 alors les six lots
dont ils apparaissent au tout début du
permien supérieur donc c'est un des
rares groupes d'ailleurs de l'un des
rares groupes de thérapie sida pas déjà
être apparue au milieu du permien non
non c'est un groupe qui apparaît du
moins pour ce qu'on en sait ô uniquement
au père bien supérieure et qui
évidemment va perdurer jusqu'à
aujourd'hui puisqu'il inclut les
mammifères mais les sinon don't know
maliens eux ne vont perdurer que jusqu
au crétacé avec les treaty l'odon idées
dont on va parler tout à l'heure alors
les 6 90 ce qui les caractérise c'est
déjà la complexité de leurs dents de
leurs mollets de leurs dents post canine
puisque au lieu d'avoir une seule qu
speed il y a trois cuts speed donc il ya
deux singles homme qui se développent de
chaque côté et qui forme les culs speed
et ça ça se retrouve dès le 6 90 le plus
banal qui s'appelle chara sonia tus et
qui vient donc delà de la zone atrophie
dos thomas c'est à dire qu'il a à peu
près entre 255 et mettons de 153
millions d'années voilà donc plus proche
de 253 d'ailleurs que 255 donc chasse au
kenya tus c'est le premier synode honte
et il a aussi un autre caractère dérivés
d'eads synodaux qui est le con deal
occipital double trait typique donc des
synodes honte et qu'on retrouve encore
aujourd'hui chez les mammifères
charasse aubenas tusa aussi un dentaire
qui est très qui est très grand donc
typiquement chez les signaux dont ce
qu'on va avoir c'est un os dentaire qui
va avoir un processus que renault est
tellement grand que généralement on va
voir le processus que renault y de
ressortir par la fausse temporal de ce
côté là voilà donc ce que vous allez
voir ça souvent chez les signaux sont
par exemple voilà chez ceux ci n'ont
dont deux sites relax au dont vous voyez
le processus corneau it qui monte ici et
qui ressort par la fausse poste orbiter
par la fausse temporal tellement il est
agrandie et ça c'est tout ça c'est de la
surface d'insertion musculaire
videmment donc encore du
perfectionnement de la mastication qui
va de pair d'ailleurs avec l'évolution
de dd dans post canine puisque les dents
post canine plus complexes vont évoluer
en parallèle avec la capacité de
mastication
on va avoir aussi une lame réfléchi deux
langues eu l'air alors au niveau de son
ornementation il va rien d'avoir
particulier par contre elle va être en
forme de cuillère voit la cuillère et
enfin en forme de cuillère quand quoi
c'est un caractère qui le rapproche des
mammifères cette forme de cuillère c'est
ni plus ni moins que la première étape
pour finir avec une bulletin panique
donc voilà ça c'est là cette forme de
cuillère elle est importante c'est la
première fois que la
que là que la lame réfléchi deux langues
eu l'air va commencer à ressembler à une
bulle en fait donc la fameuse bulletin
panique qu'elle finira par devenir
ensuite donc on a un contact entre le
nasal et le lacrymal qui est en fait qui
est en fait la en fac qui est une
manière une autre manière de formuler
j'ai envie de dire la réduction de l'os
très frontal shesha sonia tus dont klaus
préfrontal devient si réduit en fait
qu'ils ne touchent plus maxillaire et
que du coup le nasal et le lacrymal se
touchent donc ça c'est la réduction
encore une fois de la série cirque ou
morby terre qui qui se manifeste et qui
va ultimement on aura plus de préfon
talent ni de post orbitaire chez les
sino donc mais ils sont encore lâcher
sinon de base eau et on a une perte du
tabulaire et du post frontale
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu voir chez
les terros efa lien et un autre
caractère important chez 6,90 c'est la
présence de sept vertèbres cervicales
vous voyez un deux trois quatre cinq six
sept dans parlons 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 sept
vertèbres cervicales chez les sino dont
tu essaies en fait c'est le nombre
ce nombre va se fixer chez les 6 90 et
ne plus jamais ou si peu varié chez les
mammifères puisque je vous rappelle les
girafes ont un deux trois quatre cinq
six sept vertèbres et les baleines donc
ça c'est une vertèbre de baleines vous
voyez que le coût des baleines est très
très court mais vous voyez quand même un
deux trois quatre cinq six et sept
vertèbres cervicales
quelle que soit la longueur du coup chez
les mammifères on aura toujours sept
vertèbres cervicales et ça c'est
directement héritée des signaux sont
donc chez les sino dont on va avoir une
tendance à différenciation de la colonne
vertébrale en vertèbres cervicales sur
lesquels les côtes vont se réduire
jusqu'à disparaître complètement je vous
rappelle que l'axis cette côte là que
vous voyez sur l'accise ne finira par
disparaître que chez les marsupiaux et
les placentaire elle est encore présente
chez les mots notres m et on va avoir
une différenciation au niveau des
vertèbres dorsales entre les eaux entre
les côtes thoracique et les côtes
lombaire c'est ce qu'on verra dans
l'arrêt prochaine diapos donc on
escalade on escalade un petit peu le
larbre évolutif dessine au dock est la
première espèce qu'on rencontre après
chara sonia tus donc plus dérivés que
chars axiome natus ces protéines au suc
us procine au sus en français rossinot
sugus il a ceci de particulier qu'il va
qu'il commence à développer une fosse
pour l'insertion du muscle master sur
l'arcade jus galles donc sur la face
ventrale de l'arcade du gal et se muscle
masse et rc de celui que vous voyez
saint céré ici vous voyez en dessous de
l'orbité sous l'arcade légal et c'est
lui qui va donner toute sa puissance à
la mâchoire d'une part en plus de l'os
temporal mais aussi c'est lui qui va
finir par devenir les joues donc c'est
le muscle c'est le fameux muscles
zygomatiques qui va finir par former les
joues et qui va fermer la bouche
latéralement permettant ainsi la
mastication et oui c'est pour ça que je
dis depuis le début que les joues c'est
très important pour mâcher si vous
n'avez pas de joux ben tout votre bol
alimentaire il se fout l'camp par le
côté de la bouche comme chez un
crocodile ou comme chez une tortue par
exemple et non les chais les sino dont
il va y avoir développement du muscle
master qui va boucher finalement la face
latérale de la bouche permettant ainsi
de conserver le bol alimentaire quand on
mastique et ça comme je le disais ça va
aller de pair avec le développement de
dans post canine qui vont éventuellement
devenir les molaires devenir de plus en
plus complexes et rentrer en occlusion
avec les dents de la mandibule de la
mâchoire opposé vous voyez tout ça c'est
ça a évolué ensemble et la mastication
elle va aussi évolué avec la formation
du palais secondaires chez les 6 90
et oui encore une fois un palais
secondaire sauf que je peux sauf que
chez sino donc le palais secondaire vous
voyez il est uniquement
il est principalement formé par le
maxillaire et chez pro sa une et chez
pro sino su qu on voit que le maxillaire
commence à envoyer des petites
languettes sur le compte et avec les
palatins aussi
mais sans participation du vo mer vous
voyez que le veau mer là il est au
milieu il ne participe pas au palais
secondaires contrairement à ce qu'on
voit chez les terros et fall donc on a
une troisième
un troisième cas d'évolution du palais
secondaire complètement indépendant des
deux autres qui apparaît chez pro si nos
succès qui va se perfectionner qui va ce
qui va être poussée au maximum chez les
6 91 chez les mammifères
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui vous
pouvez mâché sans que vous ayez votre
nourriture qui se barre dans votre nez
et c'est pour ça que vous pouvez
respirer en même temps que vous mâcher
c'est grâce au palais secondaire et
c'est aussi grâce au palais secondaire
que vous pouvez tt le lait de votre mère
et oui le passant le palais secondaire
si vous essayez de tt ballet rire entre
par le nez il rentre pas par là bas
enfin comment diable votre capacité à tt
est complètement dû au fait que votre
langue exerce une dépression contre
votre palais secondaire et s'il n'y
avait pas cette dépression s'il n'y
avait pas le palais secondaire pour
accueillir cette dépression bah en fait
vous aspiriez de l'air par le nez
directement puisque en essayant
d'exercer la même pression en l'absence
de palets secondaire vous vous ne faites
que pompey de l'air par votre nez en
réalité donc vous ne pourriez pas tu
étais si vous n'aviez pas de palais
secondaires donc il ya pas mal de gens
qui pensent que c'est aussi à cette
époque là où du mois à partir de ce
moment là que l'allaitement a pu
commencer à devenir possible ça veut pas
dire qu'il a évolué à cette époque là
mais l'allaitement devient possible à
cette époque là chez les cyclos dont tu
donc on est au père bien supérieur là on
est à 200 plus de 250 millions d'années
252 251 on continue cette maintenant on
passe au trias
alors il n'y a pas de taxe ont connu de
6,90 qui passe définitivement la crise
permien trias mais encore une fois il ya
un effet lazare c'est à dire que les
signaux dont tu disparaisses pendant un
temps puis réapparaissent et le l'espèce
enfin le taxon qui réapparaît à ce
moment là au trias et en grande quantité
des centaines de fossiles qui ont été
retrouvés ces trine axes dont donc
trignac ce dont on le connaît très bien
sait et lui il a un palais secondaire
qui est complet justement trine axes
dont et il a les vertèbres qui sont
différenciés donc on a des vertèbres
cervicales avec des petites côtes des
vertèbres thoraciques avec des grandes
côtes dont la base est plate d'ailleurs
c'est très typique des synodes honte du
trias d'avoir des la base des côtes qui
sont plates et vous avez des vertèbres
lombaires avec des côtes complètement
réduite raccourci ce qui préfigure les
vertèbres lombaires des mammifères ou
les côtes sont totalement absentes et
vous avez les vertèbres caudales qui
sont bien différenciés aussi donc ce qui
n'était pas le cas voilà chez pro sino
sucu ce processus les vertèbres du cou
était un peu plus longue et vous n'aviez
pas de différenciation thoraco lombaire
et ça donc c'est un caractère de
mammifères
certaines personnes tant veulent
associer sa à l'apparition du diaphragme
donc le diaphragme qui ferme la région
qui est le muscle qui ferme la région
thoracique et qui permet de respirer
évidemment de pomper l'air par les
poumons c'est pas sûr sûr que ce soit
vraiment le cas mais mais c'est pas
possible c'est pas une théorie qui est
très suivi on va dire mais ça n'a pas
été non plus très très étudiée donc
pourquoi pas et donc ce qu'on va avoir
aussi chez trine axes dont là pour la
première fois c'est ce petit ce petit
comment dire cette petite projection
osseuse à l'arrière du pied
cette petite présélection osseuse à
l'arrière du pied et bien c'est le tuber
calcanéum c'est le talon c'est ni plus
ni moins que le talon d'imaginer qu'à
ventre inaction n'y avait pas de talons
voyez vous c'était le pied directement
c'était comme un reptile finalement ça a
donné le pied directement
dans le prolongement de la jambe et il
n'y avait pas de petites protubérances
pour le talon et donc il y avait un tout
petit tendon ici alors que maintenant il
ya un tendon beaucoup plus puissant qui
peut s'étendre à cet endroit là et donc
chetrit naxos dont on a aussi un très
fort on a encore une fois eu un
développement de la région delà du
dentaire avec comme je le disais le
processus corneau id très très haut mais
aussi le processus angulaire qui se
développe et qui se développe au delà de
la limite postérieur de leurs beats
donc ce processus angulaire très
fortement développés continuent de
pousser en arrière les oppose dentaire
donc la lame réfléchi mais aussi les
eaux qui deviendront les eaux circule
donc là on a vraiment un dentaire qui
domine totalement la face latérale de la
mâchoire et qui est dont la domination
de la face latérale de la mâchoire va
être encouragés par le fait que toute
cette partie là du dentaire sert
d'insertion muscles mastic acteurs qui
vont devenir de plus en plus important
au fur et à mesure que les synodes on
s'adapte de plus en plus à mâcher leur
nourriture
donc là on est vraiment dans un
phénomène de de trade off positif voilà
deux autos qui s'auto entretient donc on
va on se dirige totalement vers une
quasi-disparition des oppose dentaire
qui vont être récupérés finalement par
la mécanique de l'audition pour former
les eaux sicules et alors ce qui a comme
je le disais on trouve des centaines de
spécimens de trine action et il y en a
qui sont plus intéressantes d'autres
notamment ceux où l'on trouve des
juvéniles associés aux adultes donc
encore une fois pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas une parental où on trouve
des juvéniles associés ensemble comme
cela qu'on appelle les jumeaux où on
trouve des spécimens enroulé dans la
dernière chambre d'un terrier donc on
sait que les three naxos dont faisait
des terriers et on sait que et on les
retrouve parfois enroulés dans leur
terrier
comme si c'était des petits animaux à
sang chaud comme si c'était des chats en
fait qui qui s'enroulent est peut-être
pour hiberner voilà bon je sais que les
chats n'hibernent pas mais vous avez
l'idée quoi alors pour hiberner ou pour
estives et ça va on sait pas et alors
des fois de temps en temps leur terrier
se retrouvent parasité par une autre
espèce voyez là il ya un amphibien qui
squattent le terrier d'un tri naxos dont
peut-être justement parce que trine axe
aux dons et et à sang chaud et que ce
petit amphibien est venu chercher la
chaleur du tri naxos don ou peut-être
pour autre chose peut-être on sait que
leur fille bien avait une fracture sur
avec des fractures sur ses os sur
certains de ses os donc peut-être qu'en
fait il est juste venu chercher un abri
l'amphibien et puis bah du coup ils
étaient déjà occupés mais comme il était
en train de crever bain au final ça l'a
pas dérangé puisque ça donc on monte
dans la phylogénie on a vu les synodaux
tba zola on a fait le tour ça y est donc
ceux du permien en rouge du trias ans en
orange
maintenant on passe à 11 e sino dont tu
donc le clad qui inclut les sino
canadien envers et les pro ben attia en
bleu donc déjà qu'est ce qui caractérise
les aussi nos dont tu es bien
premièrement c'est la formule phalange
viennent les aussi 90 perdre totalement
la ces petits résidus de phalanges que
je vous ai montré qu'ils étaient
typiques des thérapies side et acquiert
finalement la fin la formule phalange
yens 2 3 3 3 3 dans 2 3 à 3 à 3 3 oui
c'est ça qui est si typique des
mammifères donc voilà tri naxos dons
envoyés avait encore ses petits résidus
de phalanges sur les doigts mais ça y
est une fois arrivés chez les e synodaux
seifallah ses phalanges surnuméraires
sont perdus enfin sont complètement
fusionné aux phalanges aux phalanges qui
elles ne sont pas surnuméraires et
surtout eh bien on va avoir une
réduction définitive ferme et définitif
de la poste dentaire qui vont devenir
cette fois complètement anecdotique sur
la mâchoire et qui vont se transformer
en cette espèce de bach ici donc là dans
la petite barque vous voyez là sur la
face interne de la mâchoire parce que là
on regarde la mâchoire par la face
interne et bien dans cette petite barle
laisse les ciseaux poste dentaire vont
tous être concentrés ici donc
donc voilà ce que ça donne en gros pour
résumer la tendance qu'on a vu depuis
tout à l'heure à la réduction du poste
des hauts postes dentaire et au
développement de l'os dentaire donc chez
les peler pélico or vous aviez cette
hausse dans la mâchoire
cette zone dans la mâchoire chetrit
naxos dont vous avez toujours cette zone
enfin non vous n'avez plus que six hauts
dans la mâchoire dont 5 g 10 6 tout à
l'heure ses cinq dont 5 parce qu'il ya
plus qu un seul chrono id
il ya encore un corner qui a été perdu
par rapport à di métro dont il y en
avait deux donc il ya cinq hausses de
poste dentaire qui sont désormais
complètement dominé par le dentaire mais
ils sont toujours là et bien développé
et en fait chez les e synodaux on a la
même condition que chez le mammifère
primitif morganucodon chez le mâle ya
forme mésozoïque morganucodon à savoir
une barre osseuse qui concentre tous les
au poste dentaire mais on a toujours
vous voyez là on al alam réfléchi dans
l'oculaire qui en forme de cuillère est
qui et qui continuent à avoir cette
forme de cuillère et qui va devenir de
plus en plus qui va porter la membrane
tympanique et qui va devenir de plus en
plus similaires à autun panique des
mammifères modernes
est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est de
comparer cette la condition chez
morganucodon à celle de l'opossum dan
opossum juvénile donc les opossums quand
ils naissent en fait les au poste
dentaire sont encore attachés au
dentaire et ce n'est que plus tard en
fait qu'on va voir donc l'équivalent de
langue eu l'air l'équivalent de
l'arctique eu l'air est l'équivalent du
quart et se séparer de la mâchoire et
formés le teint panique lac le marteau
et l'enclume qui vont être accrochés au
staps donc tympanique marteau et enclume
qui vont s'accrocher ostap s et tout ça
voilà donc là on a quasiment une en
conjuguant finalement le registre
fossile des synapses ide avec l'ontt au
génie des mammifères et avec le registre
fossile des mammifères mésozoïque qu'on
a déjà vu puisque je vous rappelle qu'on
voit les eaux se détacher en rappelez
vous que chez les mammifères mésozoïque
donc cette barre sera toujours présente
chez la plupart des mammifères
mésozoïque parce qu'on voit on continue
à voir un petit sillon dans la mâchoire
inférieure mais on va voir que
finalement ce sillon va finir par
disparaître chez les mots notres m
et chez les
et mammifères terriens donc voilà en
conjuguant toutes ces données fossiles
et honte au génie qu'est ben on a une
transformation complète une série de
transformation complète depuis une
mandibule reptilienne avec de multiples
zoo dans la mâchoire une réduction du
dentaire une réduction des oppose
dentaire et du la formation la
domination du dentaire sur la mâchoire
jusqu'à la transformation de ces eaux en
eau circule de l'oreille moyenne
et ça c'est un des plus beaux exemples
de maquereaux évolution des deux de
pluridisciplinarité aussi de des
théories de l'évolution et je veux dire
faut vous imaginer si la théorie de
l'évolution ne marchait pas faut vous
imaginer à combien de niveaux ce
scénario pourrait foiré en fait voilà
c'est il suffit que ce scénario foire
n'importe lequel des niveaux de ce
raisonnement pour que pour pouvoir dire
que là que voilà que la théorie de
l'évolution dans ce cas là ça marche
moyen si la théorie de l'évolution
marchait pas il y aurait forcément un
endroit de ce raisonnement ou south à x
ray mais non ça marche
les données morphologiques fossiles
confirme totalement les données autant
gêner on ose génétique et mêmes les
gènes du développement vont sont en
accord avec tout ça et ça c'est beau et
ça c'est beau je suis désolé c'est beau
voilà qui ose dire que la nature qui ose
se dire que la théorie de l'évolution
démystifie la nature qua non c'est beau
c'est beau les six nominés at donc le
groupe vers le groupe vert donc les
synovate déjà ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
avec le psy nominale est de remarquer
que les plus basses aux signaux mena tu
sais il ya des mots dont sont
sud-africains mais qu'après eh ben on
les retrouve partout donc en chine en
zambie en amérique du nord à madagascar
en amérique du sud l'amérique du sud
vous avez scalène ce calmer nos dons
tohid est ce exagéré taux de golfeuses
d'auto sucu cela on les retrouve aussi
en amérique du sud donc voilà ce qu'il
ya d'intéressant avec les sea dogs net
c'est déjà de savoir que c'est un groupe
qui est il ya un grand succès évolutif
et qui s'est complètement éteint voyez
c'que alléno d'auto -dès
c'est le dernier c'est le dernier à
survivre ils passent pas le joueur il
passe pas la fin du trias et c'est
intéressant parce que c'est un groupe
qui s'est adapté à l'herbe ivory donc
encore une fois le la malédiction des
herbivores des ted et synappci
d'herbivores continuent de s'abattre et
el sabah cette fois sur les six nominés
est donc les premiers sinon y'a comme
s'ils n'ont qu'une hâte us avaient des
dents qu'on appelle sectorielle donc des
danses et que d'autres si on voulait
utiliser la nomenclature la nomenclature
typique des mammifères et puis après il
ya des mots dont il a encore des dents
coupante mais il a aussi il commence à
développer des dingos faut donc dans la
partie antérieure de sa dentition
on passe donc ensuite au groupe des six
nominés at goffaux dont tu che quitte
par exemple triera codon triera caudan
kivu le voyait à une dentition qui est
purement goncourt note avec des dents
qui sont larges et en occlusion avec les
dents de la mâchoire opposé donc il ya
mastication définitivement chez les ch
et les chais les six nominés de golf au
don't et parmi les gonds fondante on
allait le groupe sud américain
principalement sud-américain des
traverso dont idées qui vont évoluer de
très grande taille qui vont devenir de
très grands mammifères de très grands si
nos deux herbivores de très gros sinon
deux herbivores vous voyez la barre
d'échelle de 4 cm la taille de ce crâne
quoi c'est assez massif et vous voyez
que les dents gombe fondante sont
réduisent en nombre mais augmentant
taille donc chez chez ces traverso dont
idées et il y à perte aussi du foramen
pariétal chez les traverso dont idée
contrairement traque aux dons via des
mots dont et sinon de natus donc voilà
la tendance évolutive à l'adaptation de
à l'adaptation à la
à l'herbe ivory on a aussi l'apparition
d'un diastème donc diastème qui est très
commun chez les ch est alors diastème
chez les traverso dont ty évidemment pas
encore chez les gauchers tous les goûts
fondante mêlée traversions dont ils ont
un système qui est aussi très commun
chez les mammifères modernes herbivores
est donc un autre caractère d'ego
fondante sais c'est le développement de
ce processus
à l'arrière du square mozal donc ce qui
s'appelle le la lame descendante du ce
comme aux halles et cette lame
descendante du square aux halles en fait
elle donne à l'arrière du crâne cette
forme en w en fait qui est très qui est
très typique voyez forme en w tak tak
qu'on retrouve aussi chez les arrières
et aux dons alors après évidemment faut
mettre le crâne faut faut manipuler
apple crâne pour voir la forme en w mais
vous voyez très bien 7
cette lame descendante du score mozal
chez sea dogs natus chez dia des mots
dont chetrit racolant schéma s'étonne
hiatus tout ça ça augmente en fait la
surface d'insertion du muscle temporal
et donc c'est encore une fois adaptation
ça donne du delà de la puissance à la
mâchoire quoi et vous avez par contre
chez les traversons dont idée ce petit
processus ventrale sur les sur les
arcade zygomatique qui augmente aussi la
surface d'insertion du master donc
encore une fois de la surface de
mastication de la surface de muscles
mastic ateurs donc voilà comment comment
les six nominés de ce soin de son parti
d'un carnivore d'un grand carnivore
comme sinon et natus et se sont adaptés
ensuite à l'herbe ivory
mmsi donc natus a définitivement
l'arrière du crâne en forme de w et le
la lame descendante du square mozal
qu'on retrouve ensuite chez tous les
chez tous les six nominés est plus gros
fonds comme fonds dont tu sais juste que
lui il avait pas encore dedans
confondante en fait
et enfin le dernier groupe de 6,90
dernier pourquoi parce que il nous
conduira aux mammifères
il s'agit des bleus c'est à dire des pro
b nokia allez les bleus donc les pro b
nos médias tiens ils vont pas se
caractériser par des caractères qui vont
les rapprocher du coût des mammifères et
là on va on va le faire que progresser
vers une condition de plus en plus ma
malienne la première étant la perte
ferme et définitif du foramen pinéale
donc on a vu que certains groupes vont
perdre le foramen pinéale on a parlé de
chant bersia on a parlé de traversons
dont il est donc avance avant les pros
benatia le foramen pinéale il va il
vient chez les sino dompter les
thériault elle été rossés fa lien chez
les pro b longue date est assez fine il
ya plus de variations on perd le foramen
pinéale complètement
et ça ça a peut-être aussi à voir avec
l'évolution de landau thermie puisque
les seuls animaux qui ont un foramen
pinéale aujourd'hui ce sont ceux qui ont
un qui ont qu'ils sont et que ce sont
des animaux ectothermes et le foramen
pinéale en fait leur indique qu'en aller
ce camp allait se mettre au soleil pour
prendre la chaleur quoi donc on va aussi
avoir une simplification du crâne qui va
continuer chez ses
chez ces problèmes il n'ya donc celle où
mme khouya qui est le plus banal des pro
b longue date y a on va avoir perte de
lectorat rigaud id donc à des eaux du
palais mais on continue à avoir le post
orbitaire voilà et le préfrontal donc
ces deux là vont être perdu un peu plus
tard on va aussi avoir chez les pros
bagdad hier un caractère qui est très
différent de chez les autres sinon tu
sais là les côtes les côtes thoracique
qui deviennent tubulaire puisqu'on avait
vu donc chetrit naxos dont que les côtes
thoracique
elle avait une zone de plats à la base
voyez ça faisait un plateau que les
mêmes cotes thoracique chez les six
nominés à terrasson aussi aplati
vous voyez à la base est bien celle et
chez les pros benatia vous voyez ici les
côtes de l'omc ou ya les côtes sont
totalement tubulaire elles ne sont pas
plate on a aussi un palais secondaire
qui est beaucoup plus étendu vers
l'arrière qui inclut une plus grande
surface du palais dont il ya les
maxillaires mais aussi une bonne partie
du palais 2d au palatin qui participent
au palais secondaire et enfin un
caractère qui est important c'est que là
la ceinture scapulaire compte la
ceinture scapulaire continue de se
simplifier chez les pros benmounia avec
l'exclusion d'un os qui s'appelle le
proco racault id de la cavité glenwood
donc en fait vous avez la cavité ici
pour l'insertion de l'humérus et ici en
fait vous avez le losc
vous avez là scapula vous avez le corac
aux idées et vous avez le proco racault
id est normalement le proco aura qu il
participe avec le corac au vide avec à
cette fausse glenwood mais là le
procureur aux idées réduit et en fait il
va finir par disparaître comme le corps
à corps il va finir par disparaître et
la première étape de cette tendance à la
disparition de saison et bien elle est
présente chez lui mme couillard et c'est
l'exclusion du proco racault id de la
khl a vite et glenn aux ide
donc voilà une simplification finalement
la première étape de la simplification
de
de la ceinture scapulaire le deuxième
voilà on va monter petit à petit dans
l'arbre des pro b nomme nadia se
rapprochant à chaque fois un peu plus
des mammifères et évidemment je ne peux
pas parler des probables hinatea sans
parler de diar trône hiatus dit art rock
natus dont le nom signifie littéralement
la mâchoire à deux articulations et
pourquoi donc la mâchoire des
articulations et bien c'est très simple
il se trouve que là en fait la limite
tel qu'on l'a défini entre mammifères et
terap side c'est une limite complètement
arbitraire elle a été définie par
l'homme pour l'homme
voilà c'est une limite arbitraire et
cette limite arbitraire et bien c'est la
transformation du delà de l'articulation
de la mâchoire donc chez les reptiles et
celle et la plupart des synapses id
l'articulation de la mâchoire se fait
entre l'oscar est ici en bleu hélas
articulaires ici en rouge
sauf que comme celle été rapide on va
avoir une réduction d au poste dentaire
donc carey et articulaires inclus et ben
au bout d'un moment l'articulation entre
le quart et l'articulent air va être
perdu au profit d'une nouvelle
articulation entre le dentaire et le
squames aux halles donc cette
articulation dentaire et squames aux
halles c'est celle qu'on retrouve
toujours aujourd'hui chez tous les
mammifères mots notres m et marsupiaux
et placentaires inclus hédiard trogi
natus et bien il se trouve et et en fait
on définit la limite entre les deux
entre tes rapide et mammifères par en
fait le moment où cette articulation
donc reptilienne est devenu plus petit
et moins fonctionnel que l'articulation
mammalienne donc l'articulation
mammalienne entre le dante et entre le
dentaire et le square mozart et dire
trop de natus et bien il se trouve que
si vous regarder dans le détail sa
mâchoire
vous voyez l'articulet receipts qui
s'articule avec un tout petit petit
carré et vous voyez le dentaire ici qui
a un petit con deal qui s'articule avec
une petite surface sur le square aux al
diyar troc natus
ah les deux types d'articulation en même
temps il a à la fois l'articulet ricard
et donc le caractère primitif reptilien
et le dentaire squames aux halles le
caractère m'a malien dérivés et ça
encore une fois c'est beau c'est un
chaînon manquant parfait voilà j'avais
fait toute une vidéo pour expliquer à
quel point dit art robin hiatus était le
chaînon manquant parfait je le dis et je
le répète dire trop de natus c'est le
chaînon manquant parfait entre les
mammifères et les thérapies side
donc voilà la prochaine fois qu'on vous
demande montrez moi un chaînon manquant
balancer du dire trop ignatus vous avez
mon autorisation
voilà c'est l'espèce intermédiaire quoi
voilà c'est c'est beau c'est beau c'est
beau et donc dia retrouve natus a vécu
alors soit à la fin du trias soit au
début du jurassique c'est pas super bien
dater tout ça voilà alors dire trop de
natus lui-même en fait fait partie d'un
groupe ferait partie d'un groupe plus
grand qui s'appelle les traiter l'eau
dont il est hélas je prononce bien
triste lots dont idée parce qu'on va
aussi voir laiterie thilo dont il est
plus tard donc les tristes lots dont
idées et donc diar trop de natus de ce
fait à des dents de trith lots dont idée
c'est à dire des dents donc qu'ils ont
trois cuts speed et qui en plus sont à
saint guillaume très épais du côté
du côté labiale si je me suis du côté
buccale vous voyez là ce saint guilhem
très épais voile à tak tak attaque qui
convoie bien là du côté labiale de sueur
sur cet autre trith lots dont idée qui
s'appelle pas qui gênait luce voilà donc
ça c'est un caractère typique de traiter
l'eau dont idées et chez les rites lots
dont idée on a aussi la disparition du
poste orbitaire qui va de pair avec la
disparition de la barre post orbitaire
voilà donc la barre post orbitaire est
perdu et l'os post orbitaire avec mais
on a aussi le spray frontale qui
disparaît donc c'est la fin de la
simplification de la la région cirque ou
morby terre c'est c'est la condition
mammalienne qui est là ça y est
d'ailleurs l'absence de bach post
orbitaire ça va se retrouver aussi chez
les chez les mammifères bazot comme
morganucodon aimé gaz austro dont par
exemple donc les les éléments poste
dentaire sont toujours en forme de
baguette ça n'a pas changé est par
contre un nouveau truc c'est que les
saints la symphyse dentaires ne laisse
un fils dentaires ne sont plus fusionner
donc vous aviez vous aviez finalement
chez les sino d'onde plus bazzo les deux
saint fils qui était fortement collées
les unes aux autres pas aussi fusionner
que chez les dicillo donc bien sûr mais
elle était fortement collées les unes
aux autres et bien chez chez les traiter
l'eau dont idée les deux symphyse en
fait sont complètement libres de bouger
indépendamment et ça encore une fois ça
va de pair avec une certaine forme de
mastication qui n'existe plus tant que
ça aujourd'hui à part chez quelques
insectivores donc c'est très
probablement une adaptation à casser de
la cuticule voilà si j'ose dire
donc chaque mandibules pouvant agir
comme une tronçonneuse indépendante de
cuticules d'insectes est aussi un
caractère nouveau sur les traiter l'eau
dont 6 décès l'apparition d'un processus
o les crânes de lunas c'est à dire
l'apparition d'un coup deux donc si vous
prenez votre coude et que vous tâtez la
boule de votre coude et bien vous êtes
en train de tâter le processus au les
crânes de votre
na et ce processus sur les crânes de
votre une assez lacération d'un tendon
très important qui se trouve à l'arrière
de votre bras et ça c'est apparu avec
les traiter l'eau dont idée voilà donc
dire trop de natus tout seul ne vous
dirai pas tout ça parce que ont ils
aient pas enfin il est connu par des
arrières crâne et des mandibules
seulement mais pas qu'ils genuis par
contre on a des on a des squelettes
complets qui viennent du jurassique
inférieur laiterie petits lots dont il
est maintenant eh bien ils ont des
caractères en plus des traités lors
d'entités qui les rendent encore plus
malien
le principal étant que vous voyez les
pipes terry gou id est tellement
développé qu'ils ferment complètement la
boîte crânienne
donc ça y est on a une boîte crânienne
maintenant qui est complètement fermée
ce qui n'était pas encore le cas avec
pâquis jean luce la boîte crânienne est
totalement fermée et les pipes terry go
id n'a point démérité son nom d'alice
fait nos idées voilà donc c'est le même
os les pipes terry gohidé la liste fait
nos rides
on a aussi chez les ch et laiteries
thilo dont il est un autre caractère qui
aima malien c'est la fusion des eaux
protic et aux pistes aux tic alors chez
les terres apside le l'oreille interne
n'est pas contenue dans un seul os qui
s'appelle le pétrole comme chez les
mammifères l'oreille interne est
contenue dans 3o le protic l'eau piste
aux tic et le supra occipital mais
maintenant le supra occipital il est
trop occupé à former toute la face
occipital parce que toute la phase de
l'occiput maintenant est dominé par
supra occipital il ya plus de ces
ripostes pariétal et du coup il
participe plus à la l'oreille interne et
lepreau au ticket l'eau piste aux tic et
ben il chez les three thilo dont il est
il fusionne et forme le pet re donc le
pronostic à l'avant et l'eau piste aux
tic à l'arrière vont former le pétrole
donc c'est l'apparition de l'ofsp est re
qui est l'os qui va contenir l'oreille
interne jusque chez les mammifères
modernes
on a aussi l'apparition d'un sternum
donc la cage thoracique continue de se
différencier chez les three thilo d'anti
des donc l'apparition d'un sternum qui
paiera qui soutient les côtes
ventre allemand chez ses chais c'était
rapide et chez les tricolores d'anti des
on va aussi avoir l'apparition en fait
d'un bassin beaucoup plus malien dans
son dans son ensemble donc voici le
bassin d'un trip d'un silo de basalte
vous voyez cette grande dame
il ya qu qui est qui il fait beaucoup
ressembler à un bassin de reptiles et
bien cette grande famille il y a que va
se transformer en petit s'il en une
sorte de cylindre en fait qu'un
cylindres il y ait toujours attaché au
évidemment à la colonne vertébrale aux
vertèbres sacré mais ça c'est la
morphologie qu'on va retrouver après
chez morgan du côlon et lmh amalia forme
du mésozoïque donc treaty l'aude on a un
bassin qui est beaucoup plus semblables
à celui des mammifères plus d arrivée et
là c'est à vue l'homme devient
extrêmement profond et s'articule avec
une tête de fémur bien distinct du corps
du fémur
est ce ce qui donne à trith îlot dans
une posture totalement érigées tôt donc
voilà on parle plus de postures semi
érigé à partir de trith il donc d'être
utile aux antilles dès on parle d'une
posture totalement érigé et laiteries
t-il aux antilles dès ils vont avoir une
répartition mondiale un succès évolutif
assez incroyable on en retrouve
absolument partout détruites ils osnt
idées partout dans le monde en chine en
amérique en amérique du nord en amérique
du sud en afrique évidemment et on va en
retrouver jusqu'au japon au crétacé et
c'est le tri c'est le groupe de sinnoh
dont tu ne m'as malien qui va avoir le
plus grand succès évolutif dans le temps
puisqu'il va survivre il va apparaître
alors possiblement au trias supérieur
mais les premières vraies enfin les
premières vraies occurrence sont au
début du jurassique et jusqu'au début du
crétacé on va avoir des treaty l'odon
petit des ae et c'est aussi on a année
un os et puis plus bien alors si vous
vous rappelez on n'avait pas on avait
parlé de la cepi pu bien chez les ch et
les carnivores et donc on avait dit que
l'os et puis pu bien allez peut-être
devenir le bas qu l'homme était
peut-être l'ancêtre du bas qu l'homme
alors chez et on avait je vous avais
montré de consignes au ghana tu ce don
qui fait partie des signataires
donc le clad verts et qui avait
possiblement un au cpie pubis
cartilagineux chez treaty l'eau dont on
a le premier répit pubis
aussi fier donc la première la première
la première fois qu'on voit un os
marsupial en fait et bien séché treaty
l'aude ont donc bien avant les
marsupiaux en fait donc voilà le fameuse
le fameux treated aux antilles des
japonais et alors vous voyez là ce qui
caractérise les treaty l'odon idée c'est
vraiment cette morphologie dentaire des
d'entrée avec tanguy l'air avec trois
rangées de deux cuts speed sur les dents
supérieures et de qui viennent socle ur
so cluzet sont plus ceux qui viennent
broyer la nourriture contre deux rangées
de cul speed des dents à deux rangées de
cul speed sur la mâchoire inférieure
donc c'est pas dur d'imaginer comment
les deux rangées de cul speed de la
mâchoire inférieure viennent se écrasé
la nourriture entre les trois rangées de
cul speed de la mâchoire supérieure avec
des mouvements propre à lino évidemment
une fois de plus
donc quand encore un caractère en commun
c'est à caractère en commun avec les
rongeurs et qui va de pair avec le
profil général des détritus l'odon idée
à savoir des animaux de de taille
moyenne
enfin petite moyenne et parfois qui
peuvent être quand même assez grand il
ya certes un grand tri kg dont il est
tout de même comme oligo qu'ils fussent
mais voilà des animaux qui vont avoir
des énormes incisive qui vont beaucoup
rappelé du coup les rongeurs voyez là
chétrite îlots dont vous avez ces deux
grosses incisive là qui rappelle pas mal
les rongeurs vous avez c'est cette crise
cette puissante mâchoire qui rappelle
beaucoup les rongeurs les mouvements
propre à lino qui rappelle les rongeurs
voilà et les dents avec ce diastème
entre les incisives et les dents
molaires qui rappelle énormément les
rongeurs et d'ailleurs l'occlusion est
poussé à un point de perfectionnement
assez assez ahurissant chez les three
t-il aux antilles des skis aussi un
caractère en commun avec les mammifères
et vous avez aussi cette très longue
crête sagittale pour l'insertion de
muscles l'instigateur une fois de plus
très développé donc maintenant est-ce
que les tripes
en fait les gens sont un peu les treaty
landon idée serait possiblement le
groupe le plus proche d
des mammifères de partout les caractères
qu'il partage avec eux mais en fait
c'est une position qui est très disputée
de part le fait que justement ils ont
cette morphologie si spécialisée est
généralement les gens préfèrent à
l'hypothèse d'être idée treaty l'odon
idée l'hypothèse de brazil y terium ou
brasil aux dons parce que les deux les
deux genres pourrait être synonyme donc
brasil y terium slash brasil aux dons
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont mieux que les
tricolores dont idées pour être les le
groupe frère des mammifères et bien ils
ont déjà le fait que leurs dents sont
pas aussi spécialisé vous voyez que les
dents sont pas des gros carrés sont pas
des groupes des grosses dents à surface
carrée à 3 q speed très très très
spécialisés ils ont pas l'espèce de
aussi de diastème ils ont pas disons des
incisives ils ont des canines bref ils
ont tout ce qu'il faut là où il faut
pour être vous pour donner finalement la
morphologie qu'on connaîtra chez les
mammifères est ce qu'ils ont en plus
chez les mâles qui va avec les maliens
forme
c'est déjà la présence de quatre
incisive inférieur donc ce qu'on va
retrouver chez les maliens forme moderne
donc au lieu de 0 chez les three titres
dont il est évidemment il y aller dans
post canine continue à se complexifier
avec une 4e qu speed qui apparaît sur
les dents post canine et cette quatrième